GOOD. AND SOME ENTERTAINMENT
CENTER YOU'RE THE LUCKY ONE
GOING FIRST TELLS THAT. WHERE DO
SUBCOMMITTEE RIGHT NOW OBVIOUSLY
ONCE WE GET A QUORUM THEN WE'LL
GO FROM THERE ABSOLUTELY I
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AB TWENTY THREE OH NINE
STRENGTHENS EXISTING JUVENILE
COURT PROCEDURES TO ORDER
GUARDIANSHIP INSTEAD OF FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENT. THE EARLY STAGES
OF A DEPENDENCY COURT CASE IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS AFTER A CHILD
IS REMOVED FROM THEIR PARENTS
CARE ARE CRITICAL THESE EARLY
COURT HEARINGS TO DETERMINE
WHERE A CHILD WILL LIVE AND WHAT
SERVICES THE FAMILY WILL RECEIVE
FOR THE MONTHS AND SOMETIMES FOR
THE YEARS TO COME. IT'S ALSO AT
THIS EARLY STAGE THAT THE
DISPROPORTIONATE REPRESENTATION
OF FAMILIES OF COLOR IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM MANIFESTS.
JUVENILE COURTS HAVE DISCRETION
UNDER WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS.
CODE SECTIONS TO ORDER A SAFE
AND PERMANENT PLAN OF
GUARDIANSHIP AS AN ALTERNATIVE
TO FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT. THIS
OPTION TYPICALLY ARISES UNDER
CERTAIN FACT PATTERNS NAMELY
WHAT APPARENT TO CLIENTS OF
FAMILY REUNIFICATION SERVICES
AFTER CONSULTATION WITH THEIR
ATTORNEY AND IDENTIFIES A FAMILY
MEMBER OR OTHER KNOWN ADULT TO
TAKE CARE OF THE CHILD THAT THE
CHILD IS STILL WITHIN THE REALM
OF THEIR FAMILY. CALIFORNIA
COURT TO DESCRIBE THIS OPTION IS
ONE OF THE LAST OPPORTUNITIES.
TO GIVE SOME DEFERENCE TO THE
PARENTS OWN PLAN FOR THEIR CHILD
AND I WOULD SAY ALSO TO ALSO-
MANY TIMES OFFER THAT CHILD SOME
LINK TO. SIBLINGS TO COUSINS TO
OTHER MEMBERS AND THEY'RE KNOWN
UNIVERSE. BUT JUVENILE COURT
STAKEHOLDERS REPORT THAT
GUARDIANSHIP IN LIEU OF FOSTER
CARE ARE NOT USUALLY CONSIDERED
EVEN WITH THAT OPTION WOULD BE
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD AND THE FAMILY. COURTS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO CONSIDER THE
PARENTS CHOICE OF GUARDIAN AND
TYPICALLY DO NOT CONSIDER
GUARDIANSHIP. UNTIL THE DISPOSAL
HEARING AFTER THE CHILD HAS BEEN
DETAINED IN FOSTER CARE FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS WHICH OF COURSE
CAN BE TRAUMATIZING FOR THE
CHILD. AB TWENTY THREE OH NINE
TO PROMOTE FAMILY DECISION
MAKING AND MINIMIZE A CHILD'S
EXPOSURE TO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. ONLY WHEN THERE'S A SAFE
AND PERMANENT GUARDIAN AVAILABLE
AND THAT WOULD BE UP THE COURT'S
DISCRETION TO DECIDE THAT
APPROPRIATENESS. THE BILL
UPDATES THE LAW BY ALLOWING THE
JUVENILE COURT TO ORDER ORDER
ORDER GUARDIANSHIP EARLIER THE
DEPENDENCY COURT PROCESS. AND
REQUIRING THE JUVENILE COURT TO
SELECT PARENTS AS ADMITTED
GUARDIAN AS LONG AS THE CHILD
SAFETY IS NOT JEOPARDIZED. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES DSS TO
COLLECT DATA ON CHILDREN LIVING
WITH A RELATIVE CAREGIVERS. THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MOST LIKELY
TO BECOME GUARDIANS UNDER THIS
BILL. WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAFF AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS OF AS
WE REFINE THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. SAMANTHA FOR WITH THE
ALLIANCE ON CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
WILL BE OUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT AND SHE IS WITH US BY
PHONE. GREAT GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
THAT AND SHARING THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
THAT THE CODE BONTA THAT SPELL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE THE
CARE GIVERS THE LION FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS HAS SPENT THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS HOSTING FOCUS
GROUPS SURVEYS AND CONVENIENCE
ON THE EXPERIENCE OF THE KINSHIP
CAREGIVERS RELATIVES WHO STEP UP
TO CARE FOR CHILDREN AFTER THOSE
CHILDREN ARE SEPARATED BY THEIR
PARENTS BY THE CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY. WE GATHER DATA FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SHOWING
THAT ALTHOUGH THE CARE GIVERS
AND THE CHILDREN THEY CARE FOR
HAVE SIMILAR GENETIC EXPERIENCES
AND COMPLEX NEEDS BUT THE VISION
MADE EARLY IN THE FAMILY'S
INVOLVEMENT WITH CHILD WELFARE.
CAN CREATE SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES. ASSEMBLY DEPORTED
REPORT A RANGE OF. AND WHETHER
PARENTS AND SHALL. ACCESS TO A-
WHETHER TO CARE. MORGAN BOOK
HEARING THE CHILL AND OTHER
FAMILY LIKE HAD A TIME IN THE
BACKED ARRANGEMENT FOR THAT. AB
TWENTY OH NINE COMES OUT OF
THESE COME. IN ATTEMPTS IDENTIFY
THE IMPORTANT JUNCTURES AN
EXISTING LEGAL PROCESSES WHERE
ONE OR MORE OF THE CRITICAL
COMPONENTS ARE MISSING. A LOT OF
THE LAST WORK TO ORDER INCIDENT
. IS ONE SUCH JUNCTURE HERE ARE
THE LAW CAN BE STRENGTHENED TO
ENSURE A FAMILY PLAN MORE OF A
DECISION MAKING ROLE AND THE
FACT THAT. IT'S SO BAD THAT BY
GIVING THE JUVENILE COURT
FLEXIBILITY SUPPORTER
GUARDIANSHIP MORE QUICKLY THAN A
LOT UNDER CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
CONSIDERATION OF THE PARENTS IN
THE NATION OF GUARDIAN AS LONG
AS THE CHILD HEALTH AND SAFETY.
ARE NOT JEOPARDIZED. I WANT TO
KNOW THE BILL ALSO WORK. THAT
THE OF THOSE SERVICES TO CALL
DATA ON THE FERRY CARE GIVER X.
THAT. THE ALLIANCE HAS BEEN. OF
THE PATH OF YEARS WITH THE GOAL
OF FOR. A MORE. WITH PART THAT
FOR ALL. THANK YOU AND WE
RESPECTFULLY. THAT BY THE- THANK
YOU. DO HAVE ANOTHER WOULD. IT'S
NEVER FRIEDMAN NOT THAT THE
CORPORATIONS AND WE HAVE IT DO
WE HAVE ANY IN PERSON A SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. KISSING NONE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE PHONES
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY- ONE ON
THE LINES FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED. JUST A MOMENT. FIND ONE
HUNDRED ONE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS JOHN CAN GO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE OH NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
. LINE SIXTY NINE. BAKER KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT. KEWLEY ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES DEPENDENCY
LAWYERS AND SUPPORT. FINAL CALL
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I WENT OUT TO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU OPERATOR WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. I DON'T
BELIEVE I SEE ANYTHING THERE SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO- ANY OPPOSITION
IN PERSON HERE. ALL RIGHT AND
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. BUT I'M
SURE THERE IS NO ONE THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
APPRECIATE THE FULL
CONSIDERATION WHEN THE COMMITTEE
. IT'S HERE I DIDN'T I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT WAS
ANYBODY ELSE HERE BUT IT WAS.
NEW STRATEGY LIKE CONNECTORS.
ABSOLUTELY OKAY. THAT I GOT A
LOT OF. RELATED. ALL OF. COMING
OUT. ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND WE'LL START WITH THEM AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY WILL OPINI SORRY. OTHER
BECAUSE SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX THANK
YOU OTHER THREE OKAY YEAH. A
TRIPLE HEADER THERE OKAY I TRY
TO BE EFFICIENT- THEY WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE TEAM- AND
STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK A TO
HELP GET US READY. ALSO SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. BUT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX A
BILL THAT WOULD CLARIFY REFERRAL
CRITERIA CONCERNING DEPENDENT
CHILDREN PLACED IN FOSTER CARE.
THERE'S A WIDE AGREEMENT WITHIN
THE CHILD WELFARE COMMITTEE AT
THE BEST THING FOR MOST CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE TO BE REUNITED
WITH THEIR FAMILIES. HOWEVER
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR CONGRESS
AGAIN MAKING STATES RECOUP THE
COSTS OF FOSTER CARE FROM
PARENTS OF FOSTER YOUTH. A
CONTRADICTORY PRACTICE THAT GOES
AGAINST THE STATED GOAL OF
FOSTER CARE WHICH IS ULTIMATELY
FAMILY REUNIFICATION. CALIFORNIA
DATA SHOWS THAT MANY PARENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY THESE EXPENSES
EXT EXPERIENCE EXTREME POVERTY.
THE PRACTICE IS WRONG ON MANY
LEVELS. HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
CHILDREN STAYING CARE CHILDREN
REMAINING CARAMEL SEVEN MONTHS
LONGER THAN IS NECESSARY. WE SAY
THAT WE SUPPORT FAMILY
REUNIFICATION BUT OUR CURRENT
LAWS MAKE IT HARDER FOR FAMILIES
TO DO JUST THAT. REUNIFY WE SAY
WE BELIEVE IN EQUITY IN THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS. RACIAL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM BUT THE IMPACTS
OF MAKING PARENTS PAY FOR FOSTER
CARE FALLS ESPECIALLY. AND MOST
ACUTELY ON BLACK FAMILIES IN
INCREASES BLACK CHILDREN'S
LENGTH OF STAY EVEN LONGER THAN
THE AVERAGE SIX PLUS MONTHS. A.
B. SIXTEEN A SIX REQUIRES CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES TO PRESUME THAT
PAYMENT OF FOSTER CARE COSTS
UNNECESSARILY EXTENDS CHILDREN'S
TIME IN FOSTER CARE. WHICH IN
MOST CASES THE DEATH AND AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE CHILDREN THIS
POLICY CARE CLARIFICATION WILL
ENSURE THAT DECISIONS ABOUT
REFERRALS ARE MADE MORE UNIFORM
ACROSS ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
WHICH WILL REDUCE. THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES REQUIRED TO PAY FOR THE
CHILD STAY IN CARE. BY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF REFERRALS. PARENTS
SEEKING TO BE REUNITED WITH
THEIR CHILDREN WILL BE ABLE
PARENTS YOU CAN BE RELY REUNITED
WITH THEIR CHILDREN WILL BE ABLE
TO USE THEIR INCOME TO
REESTABLISH THEIR HOMES AND
BUILD A THRIVING AND HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT NOT PAY BACK THE
COUNTY FOR THE TIME THE
CHILDREN. THE CHILDREN THEIR
CHILDREN WERE IN FOSTER CARE. TO
GIVE TESTIMONY TODAY I'M JOINED
BY SABRINA FORTY. A DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND IMPACT LITIGATION ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND PAULA- THE
LAST VELASQUEZ DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AGASSI FOR CW D. A.
TO TESTIFY. SOME OF SUPPORTIVE
ON THE FARM AND I'M HERE IN
PERSON I'M HAPPY TO GET US
KICKED OFF OR DO YOU WANT TO
START WITH THIS FORTY ON THE
PHONE NO PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU. OKAY AFTERNOON JAN MEMBERS
PAULA VAZQUEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. OF
THE AUTHOR NOTED THIS BELT
CLARIFIES PAYMENT REFERRAL
CRITERIA. FOR PARENTS WHOSE
CHILDREN ARE PLACED INTO FOSTER
CARE. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE TOP
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM CAN. BUT IS
NOT REQUIRED TO. MAKE A REFERRAL
FOR CHILD SUPPORT COLLECTIONS IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES. WHERE
COLLECTION OF NOT A BARRIER TO
REUNIFICATION FOR CHILDREN. THAT
HAVE BEEN INVOLUNTARILY
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS.
CWD A CO SPONSORED A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO A LAW THAT REDUCE
REFERRALS ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT
A CHILD WELFARE DEPARTMENT MUST
PRESUME THAT PAYMENTS PAYMENT OF
SUPPORT BY THE PARENT IS LIKELY
TO POSE A BARRIER TO
REUNIFICATION. THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH RESEARCH FOR
EVERY ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS THE
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVED PARENTS
PAY THEIR CHILD'S DURATION AND
KERR LENGTHENS FOR SIX POINT SIX
MONTHS. THE EFFECTS ARE
ESPECIALLY PRONOUNCED FOR
FAMILIES OF COLOR WHO ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER REPRESENTED
IN CALIFORNIA'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. FAMILIES WHO ARE
SUPPORTED BY PUBLIC SYSTEMS ARE
BETTER ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
DEPENDENCY COURT IN ORDER TO
REUNIFY REUNIFY WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. CONVERSELY ENFORCING
PAYMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT. BY
PARENTS WHO ARE FINANCIALLY
STRUGGLING GENERALLY SERVE TO
MAKE REUNIFICATION WITH THEIR
CHILDREN HARDER TO ACHIEVE AND
CAN FURTHER DESTABILIZE THE
FAMILY. THIS CHANGE EFFECTIVELY
NARROW THE CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
WOULD ALLOW CHILD WELFARE
PROFESSIONALS TO REFER PARENTS.
TO ENFORCEMENT WHILE KEEPING
TRACK KEEPING CALIFORNIA LAW
WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF FEDERAL
LAW. AS A RESULT THIS BILL WILL
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH BY ASSISTING THEM AND
REUNITE RIO UNIFYING WITH THEIR
FAMILIES I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR CARRYING THIS
LEGISLATION AND WE- RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
I KNOW WE HAVE A SEGMENT LISTED
WITNESS ON THE PHONE- OPERATOR
WE SHOULD HAVE A MISSED FORTY.
I'M HERE BINYON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU BRING A FOUR
K. ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS PROUD COOK DR
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY SIX I WANT
TO SHARE THE STORY OF ONE
INDIVIDUAL ERICA A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX
WITH UNPAYABLE TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY DUE TO CONSTRAINTS AND HER
WORK SCHEDULE. ERICA BOTTLE
PLACE AFTER CARE AND I'LL GET
TWENTY NINETEEN AFTERWARDS HE
WOULD CALL THE COURT TO RESPOND
TO IN ORDER TO PAY FOR THE COST
OF THE DAUGHTERS CARE SHE WAS
ORDERED TO PAY NINE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE DOLLARS MONTHLY SHE
FOUGHT HARD TO REDUCE TURNED OUT
TO FOUR HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH WHICH LASTED FOR
THE REST OF THE TIME HER
DAUGHTER WAS IN CARE. OF THAT
FOR MONTHS AFTERWARDS ERICA KEEP
PLAN REQUIRED HER TO COMPLETE
MULTIPLE SERVICE AND SHE DID
EVERYTHING TO GET HER CHILD BACK
TAKING PARENTING CLASSES
SPEAKING HEALTH EVALUATION AND
PARTICIPATING IN A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAM IT WAS HARD TO
HOLD ON TO HER HOUSING WITH AN
EXTRA BILL THE FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH SHE COULDN'T
MAINTAIN HER JOB BECAUSE THE
COUNTY UP SO MANY TIMES- SHOW UP
AT. AND OTHER MEETINGS THAT WERE
NOT ALWAYS APPROVED BY CURRENT
AND LEADING TO HER BEING OUT
ERICA- OPENLY REUNITE WITH
DAUGHTER AFTER NEARLY TWO. ERICA
ONE FIFTEEN CAN NOW MAKING
PARENTS PAY FOR CARE CO THE
EVERY THE CHILD WELFARE THAT FOR
MAINLY TO PROTECT AND CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES REUNIFIED WE AGREE
WITH ERICA AND RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR I BUILT ON. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY SIX HANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS FOR TAKE DO WE HAVE. ANY IN
THE ROOM. FOR SUPPORT. PLEASE
COME ON A- HI I IN AN EFFORT
MITCHELL OUT IN SOME THANK YOU.
HI LIVE WILL WITH THE WESTERN ON
LAW AND POVERTY TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU. HELLO DEFENDER HE MENACE
WITH GRACE AND CHILD POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN
KEPT KEY MCCUE CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION BOTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU OPERATOR WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
GONNA GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED.
HELLO THIS IS JONATHAN GO WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LINE. EIGHTY
EIGHT. THIS IS PARTICULARLY FROM
LOTS ANGELES DEPENDENCY LAWYERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. NINETY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
HEALTHCARE CALLING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LINE TO CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE A. B. PARDON ME.
NINE EIGHTY SIX. WHY NEED TO
SECURE LINE IS NOW OPEN. TIFFANY
WHITE WITH THE CSU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. I'M SURE THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BECAUSE THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU OPERATOR
WE'RE GONNA MOVE THEN TO
OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES EITHER
HERE OR- ON THE PHONE. WE'LL GO
AHEAD DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION-
IN PERSON HERE TO COME UP. ALL
RIGHT AND OPERATOR COMMITTEE IF
WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE. WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I'M SURE
THERE IS NO ONE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
GIPSON NONE. THIS RIGHT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH THIS IS A
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT BILL AND
MOVED OUT OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- BY.
REQUESTING THAT FAMILIES WHO
LOSE CUSTODY OF THE CHILDREN PAY
FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S TIME IN
FOSTER CARE YOU ONLY FURTHER
DESTABILIZE THE HOME
ENVIRONMENT- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AND I'VE OPENED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ONCE WE'VE CORRIMAL
WILL MOVE ON THAT AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO GO ON TO AB THIS TIME
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE THANK. YOU WE
WILL BE HERE FOR A WHILE MADAM
CHAIR I APPRECIATE THAT'S OKAY.
IT COMFORTABLE. GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN AND- GOOD TO SEE. THIS
SUMMARIZED WITHIN AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE. WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
HIRING TAX CREDIT FOR QUALIFIED
EMPLOYERS THAT PRIORITIZE HIRING
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH. I
TRADITIONALLY I'M NOT A FAN OF
TAX CREDITS FOR MANY MANY
REASONS BUT GIVEN OUR SURPLUS
GIVEN THE STATE OF OUR ECONOMY
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE BOTH A- LABOR
SHORTAGE AND A PAY EQUITY
SHORTAGE OF THIS BILLS
PARTICULARLY CLOSE. TO MY HEART
BECAUSE IT FOCUSES ON ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST POLICY
CHALLENGES AS IT RELATES TO THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. HOW DO WE
AS POLICYMAKERS CREATE AN
EQUITABLE HIRING ENVIRONMENT.
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. MANY
WHO COME FROM TRAUMA AND LACKS
SOME OF THE SKILL TRAINING THAT
OTHERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET-
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL FAMILY
STABILIZATION AND- SUPPORTS IN
THE COMMUNITY. DATA SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH. A WITH A THIRD
LIVING IN LA COUNTY ALONE. ALL
OF WHOM WILL AGE OUT AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD AND
EVERY YEAR FOUR THOUSAND.
CHILDREN AGE OUT OF THAT VERY
SYSTEM. MANY WITHOUT ANY
PARENTAL SUPPORT. OR FULLY
ESTABLISHED PLAN OF HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES
FINANCIALLY. WITH A NUMBER OF ON
STABLE TRANSITIONS AND FOSTER
CHILDREN'S LIVES TRAUMA FROM
MENTAL PHYSICAL ABUSE AND
NEGLECT AND CREATE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS TO MAKE. THE TRANSITION
OUT OF FOSTER HOME A VERY
DIFFICULT PROCESS. ACCORDING TO
THE WALDRON ACCORDING TO WALDEN
FAMILY SERVICES SIXTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF CHILDREN LEAVE
FOSTER CARE AT AGE EIGHTEEN WITH
NO PLACE TO CALL HOME. THAT'S
FOUR THOUSAND POTENTIAL TEACHERS
DOCTORS LAWYERS TECHNICIANS.
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKERS
TECHNICIANS- AND ADVOCATES WHO
LEAVE THE SYSTEM EVERY YEAR WHO
NEED HELP TRANSITIONING INTO
ADULTHOOD AND BECOMING THEIR-
FULL SELVES. WE KNOW THAT FOSU
SOME SUFFER FROM SOME OF THE
WORST EMPLOYMENT AND SELF
SUFFICIENCY OUTCOMES OF ANY
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY. WHEN
CHILDREN AGE OUT. NEARLY 20% OF
THEM IMMEDIATELY BECOME HOMELESS
OVER 40% AFTER THE FIRST YEAR.
FOR MANY IT'S A NEVER ENDING
CYCLE OF POVERTY DESPERATION- IN
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE
ESTABLISHES A TAX CREDIT OF UP
TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
ELIGIBLE FOSTER YOUTH PER YEAR
TO INCENTIVIZE BUSINESSES IN
PARTICULAR SMALL BUSINESSES
SPECIFICALLY HIGHER TRANSITION
AGE FOSTER YOUTH CREATING
CRITICAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO EXPERIENCES EARLY
UNEMPLOYMENT IS MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE LOWER FUTURE EARNINGS. AND
A GREATER LIKELIHOOD OF COMING
INTO CONTACT WITH OUR CARCERAL
SYSTEM. STEFANI TODAY I'M JOINED
BY CEO AND CO FOUNDER OF AYE
FOSTER'S. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME TODAY
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I AM ST **** AND I
FOSTER IS- ARGUABLY ONE OF THE
LARGEST OVERT EMPLOYERS OF
FOSTER YOUTH HERE IN THE STATE-
WE HIRE A HUNDRED TWENTY FOSTER
YOUTH A YEAR AND THEN WE PUT
THROUGH ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TO THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOSTER YOU THROUGH OUR
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM. THAT GETS
THEM PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT AT
OVER A HUNDRED DIFFERENT
EMPLOYERS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
WE LEARNED A COUPLE OF THINGS
ALONG THE WAY-ARE USE EVEN IN A
TIME AT SUCH AS NOW WHERE JOBS
ARE PLENTIFUL AND- QUITE FRANKLY
IF YOU CAN BREATHE YOU COULD
PROBABLY GET A JOB- BUT KEEPING
THAT JOB AND ACTUALLY MOVING
FORWARD- TOWARDS A CAREER IS A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT. SITUATION AND
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN THE EXIT
CARE I. UP ARGUABLY ARE UNDER
EMPLOYED- BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE SKILL SETS THEY HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED THEM WHILE THEY WERE
IN CARE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
WORKING. CONSISTENTLY WELL IN
CARE AND SO AS THEY EXIT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SKILLS TO TRULY
COMPETE IN THE MARKETPLACE SO
THEY MIGHT GET A JOB TODAY BUT
THEY'RE NOT KEEPING IT TOMORROW.
AS OUR NEED AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ESSENTIALLY FAIL UP SO THEY
NEED A SUPPORTED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
THEM AND EMPLOYERS CAN PROVIDE
THAT. BUT THEY BUT IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT THEY
NEED THAT TAX INCENTIVE YOU WANT
TO. HAVE THEM INVEST IN OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE THIS IS WHAT IT
WILL TAKE. SO WE ARE ALL IN
FAVOR OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE A
WE HAVE A CHRONIC UNEMPLOYMENT
OF FOSTER YOUTH IN THE STATE OF
WITH WITHIN FOUR YEARS 50% OF
FOSTER YOUTH WILL BE UNEMPLOYED.
AND THOSE THAT ARE EMPLOYED ARE
ONLY EARNING SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED A YEAR. SO GETTING THEM
PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT IN ONTO
PATHWAYS. TOWARDS CAREERS AND
LIVING WAGE IS AT EIGHT EIGHT IS
FUNDAMENTAL AND THE BEST WAY TO
DO THAT IS TO HAVE THEM- A
SCAFFOLDING INTO EMPLOYMENT WITH
A PERMANENT- COMPETITIVE
EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU IS ANOTHER WITNESS I
THINK YOU HAVE A GREAT A GREAT
LOOKING TO MOVE TO IN BROOME ME
TOO ANY SUPPORT PLEASE COME UP
YOUR NAME- AGENCY AND POSITION
THANK YOU. SUSANNA NEVIN WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU OPERATOR GOOD TO MOVE
IN SUPPORT ONLINE. LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT ONLINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS JOHN AND GO WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE THANKS SO
MUCH. BERMAN TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR THAT'S ONE ZERO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMPLIANCE
REPRESENTATIVE AND THAT AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. GONNA
LINE NUMBER NINETY FIVE THAT'S
NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KEEP RECALLING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA AND TO CHALLENGE
FAMILY SERVICES TRANSPORTED.
WITH A LINE NUMBER SEVENTY.
POLITE NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SEVENTY IF
YOU CAN CHECK YOUR CHECK GOING
FOR MUTUAL HEARING AUDIO. HI
THIS IS MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA IN
SUPPORT. ON THE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN THE TRIPLE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PHRENIC
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY RIGHT TO
TRUMP SUPPORT. WHAT THAT MEANT
I'M WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR- GONNA MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION- I DON'T SEE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES I DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
ROOM. OPERATOR IF WE CAN CHECK
THE LAST FOR A POSITION PLEASE.
OPERATIVE WE CAN CHECK FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE. COLLEGES
MANAGER. LIKE SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE GOING
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND LOOKS LIKE
PAPER MOVE THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE. CONTINUE. NUMBER COLORS
OPERATOR. MORE IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. ALRIGHT
MISTER RIGHT I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND TO ME IT'S JUST A WIN WIN- I
THINK WHAT IT DOES IS OBVIOUSLY
IT GIVES A SENSE TO- SMALL
BUSINESSES TO EMPLOY- BUT THEY
ALSO I THINK I GONNA REALIZE.
WHAT GREAT- POSITIVE AFFECTS
THAT THEY DO TO BRING THEM IN-
AND THEN IT'S A WIN WIN FOR THEM
IS FOR THE FOSTERS AS WELL
FOSTER KIDS SO- THANK YOU FOR
THIS BILL AND I WOULD BE HONORED
TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
AS WELL YOU HAVE AG. KICKED IN
GO AHEAD OF CENTER OF THE BILL.
SORRY BUT GOTTA MOVE BUT I
SECOND. AS THAT THAT'S RIGHT CAN
DO THAT. BUT WHAT WE OFTEN USE
ONE MORE AND WE'LL BE BACK. WITH
IT'S A LET'S. ON TO YOUR THIRD.
SO FAR YOU GET GOING. HERE TWO
ONE FIVE NINE. THE WILL BE. THE
LAST OF THE SERIES OF BILLS THAT
I'LL BE PRESENTING TODAY THIS
COMMITTEE- AGAIN WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEES CONSULTANTS- IN
THE CHAIR THE TEAM FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK. ATTEMPT TO BRING
THIS BILL A TODAY INTO TO GET IT
TO THE BEST FORM THAT CAN BE AN-
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE IS A
BILL THAT WILL STOP PERMANENT
FAMILY SEPARATION IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM FOR PARENTS. WHO
ARE PRE TRIAL. MEANING THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN CONVICTED OF ANY
WRONGDOING. IN OUR STATE WE HAVE
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND FOSTER
YOUTH. AND ONE CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES CASES OPEN AND IT'S OUT
OF PLACE OF OSCAR CBS REQUIRED
TO ASSESS THE ELIGIBILITY OF ALL
PARENTS FOR REUNIFICATION
SERVICES. THEY ALSO REQUIRED WAS
TO BEGIN ASSISTING THE PARENT
WITH THE PROCESS OF REUNITING
WITH THEIR CHILD. FOR PARENTS IN
CUSTODY THIS COULD INCLUDE
INVESTIGATING WHAT SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THEIR PARENTS AT
THEIR PLACE ONE CAR SERRATION.
SUCH AS ANGER MANAGEMENT CLASS
THE A IN A LIFE SKILLS. IN
HELPING THE PARENTING ROLE IN
THESE COURSES IN ADDITION TO
OTHER IN REGION REENTRY
SERVICES. THE COULD ALSO BE
MAILING SPECIALIZED INSTRUCTIONS
THAT CAN BE COMPLETED IN THE
MAIL BACK. WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
FILING. OF A CHILD WELFARE CASE
THE JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT
MUST DECIDE WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO ORDER THE PARENT INTO
REUNIFICATION SERVICES. OR IF.
THAT GROUP OF PARENTS WILL BE
BYPASSED FOR THOSE SERVICES
BECAUSE THEY FIT INTO ONE OF THE
CRITERIA THAT CAN BE DENIED
REUNIFICATION. IF PARENTS ARE BY
PASSED THE COURT WAS THAT
HEARING MAKE A PERMANENT PLAN
FOR THE CHILD WHICH COULD LEAD
TO THE TERMINATION OF PARENTAL
RIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE.
SEVENTEEN DIFFERENT BYPASS
PROVISIONS. THE PROBLEM WITH THE
PROBLEM AT THIS BILL IS TRYING
TO FIX. IS IN THE SEPARATION
PRISON PROVISION THAT CURRENTLY
STATES THAT IF YOU ARE A PARENT
WHO IS INCARCERATED. YOU CN BE
BYPASSED EVEN IF YOU HAVE NOT
YET BEEN CONVICTED OF ANY
WRONGDOING. WE NEED TO FIX THIS
. BECAUSE FOR PARENTS WHO CAN
POST BAIL WHICH IS LARGELY A
REFLECTION OF YOUR ECONOMIC
STATUS YOU WON'T BE BYPASS FOR
REUNIFICATION SERVICES BUT FOR
PARENTS WERE UNABLE TO POSTED
BAIL. REMAIN PRE TRIAL YOU COULD
LOSE CUSTODY OF YOUR CHILDREN
FOREVER AND HAVE YOUR RIGHTS
TERMINATED EVEN IF YOU ARE NEVER
FOUND CONVICTED. YOUR ULTIMATELY
ACQUITTED OR THE CASE IS
DROPPED. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS SEEKING TO DO AND WHAT IT
WILL DO IS IN THAT PROCESS OF BY
PASSING THOSE PARENTS LARGELY
BECAUSE THE ECONOMIC STATUS
PREVENTS THEM FROM POSTING BAIL.
I AM RETURNING HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES. TO GIVE TESTIMONY WITH
ME TODAY I'M JOINED BY DAVID
MYERS IS AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
DEPENDENCY LEGAL SERVICES AND
CHRISTINA CURTIS WAS AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE LOS ANGELES. DEPENDENCY
LAWYERS. THANK YOU OPERATOR IF
WE HAVE- EITHER MISS CURTIS OR
MISTER MEYERS ONLINE. YOUR HONOR
BUT I'M- MY NAME IS DAVID MYERS
AND TO THE COMMITTEE CHAIRED
MEMBERS AND GUESTS- I AM AN
ATTORNEY WHO REPRESENTS CHILDREN
AND PARENTS TO COME BEFORE
CALIFORNIA'S JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
COURT. AT YOU KNOW OUR WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE STARTS
RIGHT WITH SECTION THREE HUNDRED
POINT TWO WHICH HELD THAT THAT
OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IF YOU
ONLY BE A TEMPORARY INTERVENTION
FOR TWO REASONS ONE TO KEEP
CHILDREN SAFE AND TO STRENGTHEN
FAMILY. REMOVING CHILDREN SHOULD
NOT OCCUR UNLESS THERE ARE NO
OTHER OPTIONS. AND TERMINATING
PARENTAL RIGHTS SHOULD NEVER
OCCUR TO THE FAMILY HAVE BEEN
GIVEN A MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD. I HAVE A CLIENT
NAMED TONYA. TWO MONTHS AGO SHE
WAS ON A DATE WITH HER
BOYFRIEND. SHE KNEW HER
BOYFRIEND AS HE WAS THE FATHER
OF HER TWO YOUNG CHILDREN. BUT
SHE DID NOT KNOW THAT ON THIS
PARTICULAR DAY HER BOYFRIEND WAS
GOING TO COMMIT A SERIOUS
FELONY. GIVEN THAT TIME HE WAS
IN THE CAR. SHE TOO HAD BEEN
CHARGED WITH THAT SAME FELONY.
THE CRIMINAL COURT IS HOLDING
HER ON TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR BAIL. WHICH MEANS THAT MY
CLIENT NEEDS TO COME UP WITH
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET
OUT. THE FIGHT WITH THE STATE'S
SHE'S STILL IN JAIL. CAPITEC THE
SERVICES REMOVED HER TWO
CHILDREN. AT THE SAID HERE TODAY
. AND IF IT IF IT COMES UP FOR
GUILTY. OF CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE
PENDING BUT THEY MAY NOT BE
RESULT FROM. BUDGET ALSO A
PERSON OF. AS ARE MOST OF THE
CLIENTS WE HAVE. TWO DAYS FROM
NOW THE JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
JUDGE IS GOING TO TELL TANYA.
THAT SHE FELT TO PROTECT YOUR
CHILDREN. AND HE WILL NEVER BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET HER
CHILDREN BACK. CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES THAT CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES AND THE- COURTS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO MAKE THIS
DECISION. AND THEY DO SO WITH
GREAT FREQUENCY. THIS BILL
HOWEVER IT WILL NOT ALLOW COURTS
TO DENY FAMILIES THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REUNIFY. UNTIL OR UNLESS A
PARENT ACTUALLY CONVICTED. OF A
CRIME. AFTER THURSDAY OUR COURT
WITH THAT HEARING IN TONYA K. IN
AUGUST TO TERMINATE HER PARENTAL
RIGHTS. IF THE CHARGES ARE.
STILL PENDING SHE WILL LOSE HER
PARENTAL RIGHTS. WORSE THOUGH IF
YOU IF THE CHARGES ARE DROPPED
OR NEGOTIATED AND PARTY IS
RELEASED BEFORE AUGUST. THEN SHE
WILL HAVE TO PROVE WHY IT IS
BEST FOR HER CHILDREN THAT SHE
BE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REUNIFY MR MYERS AT EVERY COURT
LEGAL YOU TO. PLEASE THANK YOU.
YES OUR COURTS WON'T EVEN HAVE
TO GIVE HER A HEARING- THANK YOU
. THANK YOU OPERATOR IF WE COULD
GO TO THE OTHER- WITNESS- MISS
CURTIS. WHAT YES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
CURTIS AND I'M A SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY WITH THE LOS ANGELES
POLITICAL AND THE CO CHAIR OF A
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR BOTH
LOTS AND LOTS AND THE PENALTY
LAWYERS AND SAN DIEGO LEGAL
SERVICE. LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
A BIGGER HOW WELL SYSTEM IN THE
U. STATES. SO IMPROPER. FOR TEST
TODAY. I WAS CONFIDENT I'D BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT PERFECT
WITNESS TO GIVE THAT SYMPATHETIC
STORY TO SHARE WITH YOU. HOWEVER
I DO NOT HAVE ONE. NOT BECAUSE
THEY SHOULD NOT A PROBLEM A LOT
OF BANDS WITH THE BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM IS SO PREVALENT. MOST OF
OUR JOURNEYS HAVE REPRESENTED AN
INCARCERATED PARENTS. AWAITING
TRIAL WHO HAD BEEN BY PASSED BY
THE PROVISION. HOWEVER BY THE
TIME A CLIENT IF IT QUITS FOR
THE CRIMES THEY WERE CHARGED
WITH. THE DAMAGE HAVE LONG BEEN
DONE. IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
HERE HOW THE TIME WONDERS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED WHEN THE
PARENTS BY PASSED. COMPARED TO
THE TIMELINE TO CONCLUDE A
CRIMINAL CASE. WHERE THE
CRIMINAL CASE CAN AT TIMES TAKE
OVER A YEAR TO PROSECUTE. WHEN A
PARENT IS BY PATH. PARENTAL
RIGHTS CAN BE TERMINATED AND THE
CHILD FREE FOR ADOPTION AND AS
LITTLE AS SIX MONTHS. FROM THE
INITIATION. OF THE DEPENDENCY
CASES. IT MEANS THAT BY THE- IT
HAS BEEN A- FOR CRIMES. THEIR
CHILD AND LIKELY BEEN PLAYED FOR
DOC AND THEIR TIME FOR AS LONG
PAST. TO BE CLEAR. THE PROBLEM
BY LARGE AFFECT PARENTS YOU
CANNOT THEIR BAIL PARENTS OF
GREATER MEANS YOU CAN'T AFFORD
BILL WILL ABSOLUTELY BE GIVEN A
CHANCE TO GET THEIR CHILDREN
BACK IN THEIR CARE THROUGH
REUNIFICATION SERVICE BUT
APPARENTLY CANNOT WILL RISK
HAVING THEIR CHILDREN STAY FOR
ADOPTION AND A LIGHTNING PACE.
ALTHOUGH THIS LAW WHICH CREATED
WITHOUT THE CONTENT AS IT STANDS
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION THREE SIXTY ONE POINT
FIVE HE CONTINUES TO MARGINALIZE
ALREADY MARGINALIZED FAMILIES BY
PERMANENTLY REMOVING CHILDREN
FROM THEIR CARE. WHAT AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTY NINE IT WILL IMPORTANT
IT IS THE FIRST STEP FORWARD TO
STOPPING THE DISPARAGEMENT OF
FAMILIES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
WE ANY IN PERSON NEED TO SUPPORT
. PLEASE YOUR NAME AGENCY AND
POSITION. LIVE WILLIAMS WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE OPERATOR WE GO ON I THINK WE
HAVE. OPERATIVE WE CAN GO ONLINE
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY A SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT
A LINE NUMBER SIXTY NINE THAT
SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SECOND KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
SUPPORT. GOING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED ONE ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO JONATHAN GO
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE THANK YOU
. GROWING NUMBER NINETY FIVE
THAT'S NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO HOPE TEAM RECKON THE
CALIFORNIA LINE CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN STRONG SUPPORT. THE
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVEN ONE ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SKIPPING A COURT CASE
FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE SEVEN THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TOTAL CURRENT
CHILDREN BOSTON ARE CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT. THE MANAGER WITH
THAT THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. I'M NOT
SEEING ANY- ANY OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. OPERATIVE YOU GO TO
LINE IS WE'VE BEEN ANY
OPPOSITION ONLINE THANK YOU.
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION A
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE COMING
UP AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS. I FEEL
LIKE TO FINISH UP THANK YOU
AGAIN THIS BILL PASSED ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THE TWO
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE THE MOST
DISPARATE IMPACT FOR BLACK BROWN
POOR AND INDIGENOUS PEOPLE ARE
THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM AND
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND
THIS IS A DEEP INTERSECTION
BETWEEN THOSE TWO INNER CITY-
BETWEEN THOSE TWO SYSTEMS AND
IT'S AN INTERSECTION WHERE
CHILDREN ARE FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS. WHERE IF YOU ARE POOR
AND YOU ARE INCARCERATED AND YOU
CANNOT AFFORD A TO BAIL OUT YOU
CAN LOSE CUSTODY OF YOUR
CHILDREN FOREVER EVEN IF THE
CHARGES ARE DROPPED AND YOU ARE
QUITTED. AND THAT'S WRONG AND I
BELIEVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD IN THAT
PRACTICE AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SECTOR. CALDERON CALDERON
ABSENT DAVIES. ARAMBULA BONTA
AIR BRIAN HERE STONE THE
APPROVED LAST YEAR WALDRON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M GONNA
MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
BILLS AND CONSENT. FILE ITEM TO
AB TWO FOUR EIGHT ZERO ARAMBULA
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWO EIGHT ONE
ZERO ARAMBULA FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWO FOUR ZERO THREE BENNETT
WILSON. EIGHT FILE ITEM SIX A.
B. TWO FIVE SEVEN NINE BENNETT
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB TWO ONE ZERO
ZERO CARILLO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB TWO EIGHT SIX SIX CUNNINGHAM
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWO SIX
FIVE FOUR LACKEY. FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB TWO FIVE SIX NINE
WHEN AND VALLADARES FILE ITEM
TWENTY AB TWO FOUR SEVEN FIVE
QUIRK-SILVA FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR AB SIXTEEN FIFTEEN TANG
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILSON. TO
HAVE A MOTION. SECOND SECOND.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND BOTH LOCAL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR DAVIES
DAVIES I ARAMBULA. BONTA HI
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I STONE
STONE I THE VALLAPUDUA. THE
VALLAPUDUA I WALDRON. WONDERFUL
I'M JUST GOING TO CLARIFY FOR
THE RECORD- AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
ONE BERMAN HAS BEEN WITHDRAWN
FROM THE COMMITTEE BY THE
ASSEMBLY REELS COMMITTEE AND
REFERRED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
THEREFORE AB TWO EIGHT. EIGHT
ONE WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY.
FROM THE- START SIX. TWO IT.
MISTER KALRA. WELCOME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE CHARITY
STOP FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
AND ARE QUITE GLADLY ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED WOULD EXEMPT CAL
WORKS AND CALFRESH RECIPIENTS
FROM EMPLOYMENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
THREE MONTHS IF THEY STATE THAT
THEY LEFT THE JOB TO
UNPREDICTABLE SCHEDULED HOURS
ARE VIOLATIONS OF ANY WORKPLACE
RIGHTS. GRANTED TO THEM BY LOCAL
STATE OR FEDERAL LABOR LAWS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES TO
INFORM RECIPIENTS OF THEIR
WORKPLACE RIGHTS OF THE
VOLUNTARILY LEAVE A JOB.
CALFRESH AND CAL ROADS PROVIDE
CRUCIAL FINANCIAL AID AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. FOR MANY INDIVIDUALS
THE BENEFITS PROVIDED BY THESE
PROGRAMS ARE THE KEY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN STRUGGLE AND SURVIVAL.
THEREFORE CALIBRATION CALORIES
PARTICIPANTS ARE PLACED UNDER
IMMENSE PESSURE RETAIN THEIR
FULL BENEFITS AND AVOID BEING
SANCTIONED. UNDER CERTAIN
SECTORS CIRCUMSTANCES PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS MAY BE GRANTED A
GOOD BECAUSE EXEMPTION FROM
SANCTIONS THAT IS APPLIED IN
RESPONSE TO ABUSIVE OR ADVERSE
WORK ENVIRONMENTS. WHILE HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCIES CAN GRANT
EXEMPTIONS THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED
TO OFFER THEM OR INFORM PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS OF THEIR WORKPLACE
RIGHTS WHEN THEY VOLUNTARILY
LEAVE A JOB. FURTHERMORE TENNEY
WAS GOOD CAUSE EXEMPTIONS CAN
MAKE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS FEEL
PRESSURED TO REMAIN IN ABUSIVE
AND OTHERWISE INJURIOUS WORK
ENVIRONMENTS. THIS IS EXTREMELY
CONCERNING ESPECIALLY SINCE LOW
WAGE WORKERS ARE AT A HIGHER
RISK OF HAVING THEIR WORKPLACE
RIGHTS VIOLATED. RESEARCHERS
ESTIMATE THAT 4280% OF WOMEN
WORKERS EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THE RIGHT PLACE WITH
MORE. WITH WITH MORE INCIDENCES
FOUND IN LOW WAGE WORK. AB
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED BUT ALSO
OFFER A TWELVE WEEK EMPLOYMENT
EXEMPTION TO PARENTS IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THEY GIVE BIRTH TO A
DOCTOR FOSTER CHILD. THIS
EXEMPTION INCLUDES NON BIRTHING
PARENTS THAT AND THE TIME IT
GRANTS WOULD NOT BE COUNTED
UNDER ANY OTHER EXEMPTION. THIS
TWELVE WEEK EXEMPTION GIVES NEW
PARENTS CRUCIAL TIME TO BOND%
WITH THEIR BABIES ALLOWS THEM TO
BE PRESENT. AS ADOPTED AND
FOSTER CHILDREN ADJUST TO THEIR
NEW HOMES. THIS BILL WITH A
QUICK CAL FASHION CALPERS
PARTICIPANTS WITH THE MEANS TO
IDENTIFY WORKPLACE MISTREATMENT
OBTAIN GOOD CAUSE EXEMPTIONS AND
BE PRESENT FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
BY EMPOWERING OTHER BROKERS IN
THESE WAYS WE WILL BY EXTENSION
RAISE UP ALL OF SOCIETY. WITH ME
PROVIDES TESTIMONY. ARE MICHAEL
IT DOESN'T BACK UP I GOT IT I
GOT IT STAYS TO BE ALTHOUGH WITH
AID OR ND- GROCERY ALLEGRI
UNITED FOR RESPECT. GREAT BOTH
ON MY ON THE PHONE OPERATOR.
WE HAD A JOINT FOR THE
CHECKPOINT COMMUTE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STACEY
GALLUP AND THE FACT THE TURNING
LEGAL AID AT WORK A NONPROFIT
PUBLIC INTEREST LEGAL
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
THE EPLOYMENT RIGHT BELOW EACH
RECORD I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY THE CO SPONSOR AND TO
EXPRESS THEIR STRONG WORK FOR AB
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED. AB TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED ONE SURE THAT
POWER CALPERS FOR TO SPEND. DO
NOT HAVE TO ENTER SB SEVEN
UNLAWFUL WORKING CONDITION. FOR
FEAR OF LOSING THEIR BENEFITS.
BENEFITS THAT HELP KEEP IT ON
THE TABLE AND A REFER THEM OVER
THE HEAD OF THE STAGGERING
NEARLY HALF OF CALIFORNIAN
CHILDREN. RECEIVE CAL WORKS OF
TOP RUSH BENEFITS BY THE TIME HE
TURNED BACK. AT LEGAL AID AT
WORK WE OFTEN HEAR FROM
INDIVIDUAL TO BILL PASSED IN
JOBS BARELY RIGHT. JUST ABOUT
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THEIR
FAMILIES IF THEY LOSE BOTH THEIR
INCOME AND THEIR BENEFITS. I
WANT TO SHARE ONE SUCH STORY.
JANE WAS THE CASHIER WHO WAS
SEXUALLY HARASSED BERMAN. TO
RECEIVE HER POWER TO BENEFIT.
EVERY MONTH SHE HAD TO HAVE HER
MANAGER SIGN A FORM HE USED THIS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO GROW HER.
PRESSURE HER INTO DATE AND
COMMENT ON HER BODY. EVENTUALLY
SHE COULDN'T BEAR ANY LONGER AND
QUIT. IN RESPONSE HER COUNTY
THINKS OF HER. SHE AND HER
CHILDREN FOUND THEMSELVES HUNGRY
IN THE DARK UNABLE TO PAY THE
LIGHT BILL AND ALMOST A BIT.
WELL WE DO. LIKE JANE ARE
PARTICULARLY. TO HARASSMENT. AND
ABUSE. THEY CONTEND WITH WAGED.
AND PREDICTABLE SCHEDULE AND
LIMITED ACCESS BE FIFTY CARE
DAILY NEEDS. BY PATIENT. AND
OTHER CREW WORK PROTECT. I THE
SAME TIME THE OF BOOKS SERVICES
FOUND IN A SHE DOES NINETEEN
OVER. THAT WIND THREE FIVE ON
AVERAGE WERE ANYTHING AND
PREVIOUS. YEAR HE THINKS AND
THIS OF COURSE IMPACTS BLACK
BROWN WORK. WITH ONE FINDING
AFRICAN OR- ONE ONE POINT SEVEN
THREE MORE TO BE. BEEN WHITE
RECIPIENT WHICH IS ALL THE MORE
TROUBLING GIVEN RACIST AND
SEXIST ORIGINS OF THE WORK. IT
ALL THAT HARKEN BACK TO WELFARE
OF. NO ONE SHOULD BE FORCED TO
MAKE THE CHOI THAT JANE DEAD AND
EIGHTY TWENTY THREE HUNDRED WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT NO ONE DOES.
FOR THESE REASONS THE RESPECT
ASK FOR YOUR AB ON THE IMPORTANT
LIVE. TO FOR INCOME FAMILIES
THANK. NEXT DEGREE IN. OPERATOR
WE COULD SEE IF WE HAVE MR GREEN
ONLINE. MISTER MISTER GREEN IS
ONLINE THEY DISTINCT ON MUTE
THEMSELVES. I'M SORRY HELLO. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SHEILA GREEN
AND I LIVE IN LANCASTER LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA I AM
ORGANIZER WE UNITED FOR RESPECT
AND A SINGLE MOTHER I'M A FORMER
CHILD RECIPIENTS.I AM HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY AS A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE AB TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED. AS A PART OF CAL
WORDS WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAM I
WORKED AT WALMART THREE YEARS I
WAS MAKING NINE DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY CENTS. AN HOUR AND I
COULD BARELY MAKE ENDS MEET.
WHILE I WAS TAKING CARE OF
MYSELF AND MY FIVE CHILDREN MY
FIVE YEAR OLD GARDEN SORRY AT
WALMART I WITNESSED HOW THE
COMPANY DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
PREGNANT PEOPLE BY CUTTING THEIR
HOURS LETTING THEM GO ARE
FORCING THEM TO DO HEAVY MANUAL
LABOR DESPITE THEIR PREGNANCY.
SOME OF MY COWORKERS HAD
DISABILITY DISABILITY CUTTING
SYMPTOMS INCLUDING MORNING
SICKNESS SWOLLEN CREEK FATIGUE
AND DEHYDRATION AND WALMART
REFUSED TO PROVIDE A SAFE AND
HEALTHY ACCOMMODATION SO THAT
THEY COULD. CONTINUE TO WORK I
SAW WOMEN WHO HAD MISCARRIAGES
IN THE RESTROOM BECAUSE THEY
WERE LIFTING. OVER FIFTY POUNDS
OF PRODUCTS IT WAS HORRIFIC FOR
CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS IT FELT
LIKE. THERE WAS NOTHING WE COULD
DO. WE NEEDED OUR JOBS TO KEEP
RECEIVING TOWERS BEEN A FREE AND
WE AND DURING THE HARASSMENT
WHEN I BECAME PREGNANT I DECIDED
TO HIDE MY PREGNANCY SO I
WOULDN'T BE TERMINATED ARE
PUSHED OUT EARLY. AT GET RICH
LOSING THE CHILD. CARE
ASSISTANCE THAT I RECEIVED FROM
CHILD WORDS IF I WAS PUSHED OUT
EARLY I FELT IT FELT HUMILIATING
AND CONTROLLING THAT I HAD TO
HIDE MY BEAUTIFUL BABY. BUT I'VE
LIKE I HAVE ANOTHER. THEN WHEN I
TO FIGHT THE TO GIVE THE CAN DO
WE FACE WALMART FIRED ME I WILL
SOBRE BECAUSE I KNEW I COULD
LOSE MY CAO WORKS BENEFIT EVEN
THOUGH WE WERE JUST TRYING TO
FIGHT FOR OUR RIGHTS. NO VIEW
THE BASEMENTS RIGHT YOU COULD
FINISH UP THAT WOULD BE GREAT
THANK YOU. OKAY NO ONE SHOULD
FACE THE CHOICE OF HAVING TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN HAVING A HEALTHY
CHILD ARE LOSING THEIR CHILD
CARE- I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE AB TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED TO CREATE A SAFER AND
HEALTHIER CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR LETTING ME SHARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO THE ROOM IF WE HAVE ANY ME TO
SUPPORT. A MAN CHAIR MY CARROLL
WITH WESTERNS ON LAW POVERTY
WERE A SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE.
AND I'M ALSO PROUD TO BE A
MENTOR OF THE SLEAZE POLICY
INSTITUTE WHICH ARE THE GROUP
THAT'S BROUGHT THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OPERATOR IF
WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT ONLINE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED. HELLO JONATHAN GO
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO THREE ZERO ZERO. FIND ONE
TWENTY THREE. WE HAVE AN EQUAL
RIGHT ADVOCATES CHARM CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
FIVE. MY AND HIGHER ON BEHALF
THE MARKET BY INSTANCE THE PART
. BYE BYE. TWENTY SIX. FINALLY
THE BALLOT BEHALF CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP AND SILENT BEFORE IT
I LINE ONE EIGHTEEN. ANYWAY
SIMPLE SB YOU COUPLE IN SUPPORT
. LINE ONE TWENTY ONE. CORINNE
I'M VERY I'M A STOPPAGE AT WORK
A WORK BECAUSE AND AB TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED THANK YOU. LINE
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON A LOT OF
WITH THE TROUT CARE LOS AND OF
AB THREE THANK YOU. BY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON HOPE PAYMENT INTO
SUPPORT OF A TWENTY HUNDRED AND
CAP TO TELL LINE THOUSAND
SERVICE. BYE BYE NO.
CALIFORNIANS DISAPPEARING RIGHTS
AND SUPPORT. NINE ONE TWO SEVEN.
EIGHTY WATER MATH BUT THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND COALITION
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED THANK YOU.
MY MIND. TWENTY TWO. LIBBY
BENEDICT WOMEN'S FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA'S BELIEVES POLICY
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE SEVERAL ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS
TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THREE MONTH.
LINE ONE TWENTY NINE. BY ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI THIS IS FAMILY WITH THE
LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
AT THIS. LINE ONE. EIGHT HI MY
NAME IS OPTIMAL ARMED YES- FACT
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED. AND I'M
SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU OPERATOR ERROR WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO- OPPOSITION
WITNESSES I DON'T SEE ANY-
WITNESSES OPPOSING. DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. AND
THE OPERATOR IF WE CAN GO TO SEE
THIS THE OPPOSITION ONLINE
PLEASE. BUT ANYONE WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE. THANK YOU OPERATOR.
GOING TO MOVE ON TO- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WITH
NUMBERS. IF YOU'D LIKE. GOOD
LUCK TO BOTH SPECTOR S. RIVAL.
WHAT IS THE BEST CONTACT WE'VE
GOT A FIRST WITH A SECOND. THE
MOTION TO PASS AMENDED TO A PRO
APPROACH. DAVIES I DAVIES AYE
ARAM. BONTA I BONTA AYE BRIAN.
STONE STONE I BE A PRODUCER IF
YOU DO AYE WALDRON. THAT'S FOUR
ZERO THANK YOU. WE'LL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO SOME REMEMBER
ALMOST. AB. TWO SIX SIX THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- THAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOU COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THERE HAS BEEN
AN INCREASE IN LGBTQ YOUTH OF
COLOR TRAVEL CHILDREN. IN FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS. THE
LONELINESS LACK OF FORMAL
SUPPORT SYSTEMS AND SOCIAL
ISOLATIONS THEY ARE ALL.
EXPERIENCING HAVE INCREASED
DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND SUBSTANCE
MISUSE WITHIN THESE COMMUNITIES
. LGBT Q. N. U. WHOSE FAMILIES
DO NOT SHOW ACCEPTED BEHAVIOR
ARE ALWAYS SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
LIKELY TO ENTER FOSTER CARE OR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THAN ANY
OTHER GROUP. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
COVERT NINETEEN HAS ALSO
INCREASED THE RATE OF EDUCATION
DISRUPTION FAMILY CONFLICTS AND
USE UNDER EIGHTEEN WHO IDENTIFY
AS LGBTQ BEING KICKED OUT OF
THEIR FAMILY HOMES. WE BELIEVE.
THAT WITH CONCRETE INFORMATION
AND GUIDANCE PARENTS CAN AFFIRM
AND SUPPORT THEIR LGBTQ AND
GENDER EXPANSIVE CHILDREN THUS
FAMILIES REMAIN INTACT AND
FAMILIES PREVIOUSLY SEPARATED
CAN BE REUNIFIED. THE YOUTH
ACCEPTANCE PROJECT FACILITATED
BY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FAMILY
BUILDERS IS AN EXISTING
INTERVENTION WORKING WITH THE
FAMILIES OF LGBTQ AND GENDER
EXPANSIVE CHILDREN AND YOU IN
GENERAL. THE INTERVENTION
SERVICES SERVES AS A FAMILY
PRESERVATION AND FAMILY YOU RE
UNIFICATION TOOL ASSISTING
FAMILIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THE SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR GENDER
IDENTITY EXPRESSION OF THEIR
CHILD. THE CLINICIANS USE A
TRAUMA INFORMACIJE CO
EDUCATIONAL MODEL TO ADDRESS THE
MISINFORMATION RESISTANCE FEAR
AND GRIEF THAT FAMILIES CAN
OFTEN STRUGGLE WITH. THIS MODEL
IS INTENTIONALLY RESPONSIVE TO
THE FAMILY'S EXPERIENCES WITHIN
THEIR OWN CULTURE RELIGION AND
RACE. AB TWO SIX SIX THREE WOULD
TRANSFORM THE YOUTH ACCEPTANCE
PROJECT INTO A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM ACROSS AT LEAST THREE
COUNTIES INCLUDING SAMBAR DINO.
THIS BILL WOULD SPARK ADDITIONAL
COUNTY AND REGIONAL
COLLABORATION TO ADDRESS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF LGBTQ
YOUTH WHO ARE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES. THE YOUTH
ACCEPTANCE PROJECT IS DESIGNED
TO WORK BOTH WITH FAMILIES OF
CHILDREN ALREADY IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND FAMILIES OF
CHILDREN AT RISK OF EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE ENTERING THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. AB TWO SIX
SIX THREE WOULD EXPAND THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF YAP
INTERVENTIONS WHICH ARE DESIGNED
TO INCREASE ACCEPTANCE OF LGBTQ
CHILDREN AMONG PARENTS PARENTS
CARE GIVERS TRIBAL MEMBERS
FOSTER PARENTS ADOPTIVE PARENTS
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS AND ADDITIONAL
STAFF INVOLVED. IN CHILD CARE
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE ADRIAN
SHELTON WITH A CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE NVDA CAVELL ARE WHO IS
THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
YOUTH ACCEPTANCE PROJECT. PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ADRIAN SHELTON I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
SERVING CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND
FAMILIES IN PUBLIC HUMAN
SERVICES SYSTEMS. WE'RE VERY
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB TWO SIX SIX
THREE TODAY- THIS BILL AIMS TO
HELP ONE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
OVER REPRESENTED POPULATIONS IN
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS AND NOT AS
LGBTQ AND GENDER EXPANSIVE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT FAMILY REJECTION AS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR AND THE
NUMBER OF LGBTQ YOUTH WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR WHO
ARE IMPACTED BY THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM OR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEMS. THIS PAST YEAR
PAST TWO YEARS HAVE BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT FOR SO MANY AND WE
KNOW THAT LGBT Q. YOU HAVE FACED
EVEN GREATER AND UNIQUE
CHALLENGES ONE HEARTBREAKING
STATISTICS FROM THE TREVOR
PROJECT'S TWENTY TWENTY ONE. A
NATIONAL SURVEY IS THAT 42% OF
LGBTQ YOUTH SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED
SUICIDE IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR
INCLUDING MORE THAN HALF OF
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
YOUTH. SO IN THE WAKE OF THE
DISCRIMINATORY LEGISLATION THAT
WE ARE SEEING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THIS BILL REALLY OFFERS A BRIGHT
SPOT AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
BETTER FOR THIS POPULATION. BY
EXPANDING A PROVEN MODEL OF
INTERVENTION TO PREVENT LGBTQ
PLUS HOMELESSNESS TO SUPPORT TO
SUPPORT FAMILY ACCEPTANCE AND
PERMANENCY. AND SO WITH US ALSO
ON THE PHONE TO TALK A BIT MORE
ABOUT THE YOUTH ACCEPTANCE
PROJECT AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
FAMILY BUILDERS VIDAK KABA.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAMES TRAVEL MY NAME IS
UNITS OF OUR AND I'M FAMILY BILL
THIS POLITICAL DIRECTOR THE US
ACCEPTANCE PROJECT BELIEVES THAT
PARENTS LOVE THEIR CHILDREN WE
ARE ABLE TO SIT WITH THE PARENTS
CARE GIVER OF LGBTQ PLUS
CHILDREN AND LISTEN TO THEIR
FEARS GRIEF GUILT AND ALL OTHER
EMOTIONS THEY MIGHT BE
EXPERIENCING AS A RESULT OF
FINDING OUT THAT THEIR CHILDREN
IS LGBTQ PLUS. WE HOLD THE HANDS
OF THE PARENTS FOR THEIR OWN
JOURNEY OF UNDERSTANDING THEIR
CHILD WE HELP THEM REALIZE WHAT
THEIR CHILDREN ARE GOING THROUGH
AND TOOK THE TIME TO HELP THEM
THROUGH THIS CRISIS TO BECOME
THE LOVING FROM PARENTS THEIR
CHILDREN NEED THEM TO BE. OUR
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE SUCCESSFUL
AT KEEPING TOGETHER AS WELL AS
REDUCE THEM CHAO WILL HAS
INVOLVED WITH THE FAMILIES ALL
OF LIFE WE DIG INTO THE-
HOLSCHER BRIDGE AND BACK. AND WE
SUPPORT THEM WE LET THEM SORT
OUT THEIR FEELINGS OF LIFE THEIR
CHEN WE ALSO WORK WITH LGBT CHIU
SUPPORT THE USE HOLD ON WELL
THAT WORKED THERE FEEL. RESEARCH
THAT COSTA SAID PERCENT OF ALL
HOPE CHILL IN THAT I CAN'T FIND
THE PLUS IMAGINE IF YOU COULD
PLEASETHESE. IF GIVEN FROM FROM
THEIR HOME FOR THE FIRST PLACE
THE TERM IMPROPER RESEARCH FOR
US THAT PLUS TWO WHO FOR CARE
BIRTH TIMES MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
IT SO THE YOUTH THAT THE EXCEPT
ACROSS CAN MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD ABOUT
PLUS YOU AND FAMILY. THE YOUTH
EXCEPT PROJECT GOAL IS ELGIN TO
TELL TO BE LOVE WHO THEY ARE AND
ABLE TO HAVE A CHANGE AND LOVED
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED. HI THIS IS JOHN TO GO
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WHY ONE
HUNDRED ELEVEN. HEY. ONE ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO- OPPOSITION WITNESSES. I
DON'T SEE ANY OPPOSITION FOR
WITNESSES HERE. OR WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON A IN THE ROOM ANY
OPPOSITION. OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD GO TO THE LINES TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION PLACE.
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE
ZERO. BUT I'M SURE THERE IS NO
ONE. THANK YOU OPERATOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS. K.
MISTRUST RESTAURANTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU THANK A
MEASURE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AB
SIX TWO SIX SIX THREE PROVIDES
FAMILY REUNIFICATION AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. WITH THE BILL
. THANK YOU WILL GET A FIRST.
PLEASE KALRA. THE MOTION IS THE
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DAVIES
DAVIES NOT VOTING ARAMBULA BONTA
HI BONTA I BRIAN. STONE STONE I
BE A BOUDOIR GOOD LUCK I WALDRON. I BELIEVE THAT WE LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR ROLL CALL. THIS OKAY
NOT BE AS MEMBERS OF. THANK YOU
SURROUNDS THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT. OKAY I JUST KEEP GOING.
MY HUSBAND IT JUST I DON'T STOP
REMOVED- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
SOMEBODY MEMBER- RIVAS. THIS IS
A B. TWO H. THREE TWO. GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY SISTER DAVIES
SECRETIVE. BUT HERE THIS
AFTERNOON. AND SO. SO TODAY THE
NEED TO PROVIDE QUALITY SUPPORT
FOR CHILDREN HAS NEVER NEVER
BEEN GREATER HIS LEGISLATION
ASSEMBLY BILL A TWO EIGHT THREE
TWO SIX TWO STATUS A SCREENING
TOOL THAT WOULD ALLOW OUR STATE
TO BEST IDENTIFY- THE AREAS OF
HIGHEST NEED WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ALLOCATION OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION RESOURCES- DUE TO
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC INEQUALITIES
AND INEQUITIES. CURRENTLY OUR
STATE USES STATE MEDIAN INCOME
TO ALLOCATE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FUNDING AND RESOURCES
TO COUNTIES- AND WHILE INCOME IS
A CRITICAL FACTOR IT'S NOT THE
ONLY FACTOR YOU ARE EXISTING
SYSTEM DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR
OTHER FACTORS LIKE HEALTH
INEQUITIES HOUSING ACCESS IN
OTHER ISSUES OR FACTORS. THAT WE
KNOW AFFECT A CHILD'S WELL
BEING- AND THE LONG TERM SOCIAL
COGNITIVE EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
DEVELOPMENT. BY LEVERAGING
EXISTING STATEWIDE INDICES THAT
MEASURE COMMUNITY LEVEL TRENDS-
THIS LEGISLATION SEEKS TO USE
SUCH DATA. AND MORE TO BUILD A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK. IN
STAKEHOLDER INPUT PROCESS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE EQUITY
NEED- AND THE EQUITY NEEDS- AND
THE SYSTEMIC BARRIERS THAT ARE
IMPACTING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR CHILDREN IN DIFFERENT WAYS-
AND THAT WILL ALLOW OUR STATE TO
MAKE FUTURE MEANINGFUL
INVESTMENTS WHERE IT IS NEEDED
MOST- IS A WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE. R. VICKY
RAMOS HERIS ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA
AND MARIO RUIZ ON BEHALF OF THE
INNER CITY STRUGGLE WITH THAT
THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU OPERATOR. THE LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS JR
CALDERON AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AGAIN OF YOU'RE ALMOST FERRIS
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
WITH THE BEST BUDGET CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE SO PROUD TO SUPPORT
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO A
BILL THAT WOULD DEVELOP EQUITY
TOOL TO ADDRESS THE RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS HAVE GUESTS
CHILDREN. THE RESEARCH IS CLEAR
THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD IS A
CRITICAL PERIOD THAT PROFOUNDLY
IMPACTS CHILDREN'S LONG TERM
SUCCESS AND ECONOMISTS ARE CLEAR
THAT WE GET THE GREATEST RETURN
ON OUR INVESTMENT WHEN WE INVEST
EARLY IN CHILDREN WITH HOLISTIC
SUPPORT AND THAT THE RETURN IS
EVEN GREATER WE NEED WHEN WE
INVEST IN THOSE AFRAID TO SAY
IT. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEES I VOTE AND I AM HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. I WILL NOT PASS IT ON
TO MATURITY. RESPECT ON EQUITY
APPROACH. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON MY DENTURE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIND ANYBODY
AT LEAST I'M NOT HIDING WITH
UNION CITY TRAVEL AND WE DID THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO
BECAUSE YOU WILL CREATE A WHOLE
CHAU IT WOULD BE SCREENING TOOL
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
YOUNGEST CHILDREN YOU KNOW MORE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED AT ADMITTED
THEIR RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES. THEY SAY THROUGH. NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN. WE DON'T GO
. FOUND FAMILIES HAVE MORE VALUE
THAT ALL. ON BOTH VAN THE
TECHNIQUE IN FACT POWER TO. WE
CAN JUST LOOK AT FORWARD. THIS
CALL WE NEED TO UNDER. THAT
PEOPLE THAT MAKE THE- WELL WHAT
OUR CHILDREN. SUCH UPSCALE I
DON'T THINK WE YOU SHOULD BE IN
THE COMMUNITY. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT ALL PROOFS THE MORE
CHALLENGE GET THE EXTRA THEY
NEED. I'M ONE OF THE PATTERN WHO
FOR A STUDENT THANK YOU NEED
INDEX AT L. A. U. S. THE- I HAVE
TEAMED UP BY WORK FOR FACT. OF
USING KIND OF EQUITY APPROACH
FOR. I HOW MY OLD HOW SPOKEN
OKAY TO HELP THEY NEED YOU TO
OPEN SUPPORT ON. TO THE WOULD BE
A GOING TO LOOK FOR MY CHILDREN
I KNOW THERE FONG. WHO FACING
ISSUE. WELL YOU KNOW HOW
POWERFUL A FULL CHILD EQUITIES
TO CAN BE TO ENSURE DON'T YOU.
AND THEIR FAMILIES IN OUT YOU
NEED FOR ME TO. HAVE THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED BECAUSE THE FUND YOU
CREATE A THE MORE BECAUSE- FOR
COMMUNITY THAT WE ARE STRUGGLING
WE NEED THESE EQUITY. LOUGHMORE
THAN EVER. THAT WOULD ACROSS HAS
BEEN CRITICAL TO COOPER THE-
GROUP CALLED AT L. A. U. S. B. I
MEAN WE BE CROSS FOR THE
YOUNGER. AFTER THE STATE WILL
CALL. I SUSPECT WILL REQUIRE
YOUR I. ON AB TWO EIGHT FORTY
TWO. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ABOUT EIGHTEEN AND WITH VISA
MASTERCARD ACCOUNT FROM HERE I'D
- THE PROBLEMS YOU'RE DONE
REQUEST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR ABOUT. FIND. ELEVEN FIVE
ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. RANDY HICKS CALIFORNIA TO
DISABILITY RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE ONE THIRTY TELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS
THIS IS EDWIN BARBAULD ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THIRTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MONEY GRAM OF SOME BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
. BLIND. ONE OH THREE.
CUMBERLANDS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT
. IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I'M SURE THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES FOR
OPPOSITION HERE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ANYBODY OF FOR
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM FOR ME TO
. I PREFER COULD MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION
PLEASE. THE YOUR OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ADAM CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS. A SECOND WAS
GREAT ALL RIGHT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS REFLECT ASK FOR I'VE
A MEASURE. WE'VE GOT A MOTION
AND SECOND SECRETARY COULD DO
THE KALRA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DAVIS HIGH DAVIS I
ARAMBULA. BONTA I BONTA I'D
BRIAN STONE STONE I THE ABUJA
THE ABUJA I WALDRON. WHICH YOU
THAT'S FOUR ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
YOUR UP. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN THE IT
TAKES A VILLAGE ACT IT TAKES A
VILLAGE COMES FROM THE AFRICAN
PROVERB IT TAKES A VILLAGE TO
RAISE A CHILD APPLYING THAT
SYMBOL PROVERB TO CALIFORNIA
TODAY MEANS ENSURING CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE FULL ACT ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITIES AND SERVICES
FROM BIRTH TO CAREER ENABLING
THEM TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL IN LIFE. MEMBERS OF
THIS HAS BEEN MY LIFE'S WORK I
AT NO FROM EXPERIENCE THAT
PLAYSPACE CRADLE TO CAREER
APPROACH IS TO MAKE A WORLD OF
DIFFERENCE PRIOR TO JOINING YOU
ON THE GREEN CARPET I SERVED AS
THE CEO OF OAKLAND PROMISE A
PLACE BASED CRADLE TO CAREER
INITIATIVE FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING POVERTY
ACROSS OAKLAND PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THERE I SAW FIRST HAND THE WAYS
IN WHICH THE SYSTEMS IN OUR
STATE OFTEN FEEL THOSE WHO WE
ARE PRETENDING TO SERVE. I ALSO
SAW THE POWER OF CROSS SECTOR
COORDINATION AND WHAT IT CAN DO
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE WHY I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHES A
THREE YEAR GRANT PROGRAM. TO
FUND ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING
PLACE BASED SERVICES TO CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES FROM BIRTH THROUGH
COLLEGE AND CAREER. OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND OTHER PLACE
BASED CRADLE TO CAREER NETWORK
NETWORKS HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
WORK. THEY HAVE COORDINATED
SERVICES AND SUPPORTED ALLY AND
SUPPORTS ALIGNED WITH THE NEEDS
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES. AREAS
WHERE TEY OPERATE HAVE SEEN
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS IN
HEALTH CARE ACCESS LITERACY AND
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS. AS
SHORT TERM FEDERAL AND STATE
COURT NINETEEN RELIEF FALLS AWAY
. AS ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDING
EXPIRES THIS YEAR FOR
ORGANIZATION SERVING FELL. OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THE NEED FOR
STATE FUNDING IS GREATER NOW
MORE THAN EVER. WE MUST INVEST
IN THESE PLACE BASED SUPPORT
SYSTEMS AND ENSURE CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEEDTO
THRIVE. BY ENSURING COORDINATED
INVESTMENT AND SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN EXPANDS CALIFORNIA'S
CAPACITY TO CHALLENGE POVERTY.
ADDRESS DISPARITIES AND PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES FROM CRADLE TO CAREER.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE RICHARD
RIVA. CHIEF STRATEGY OFFICER AT
THE MISSION ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY ONE OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAS DOING DOING DOING THIS
BACKBONE WORK CRADLE TO CAREER
FOR. I THINK ALMOST A DECADE AS
FOR. AND LINDA GLEASON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE FRESNO. YOUR
SHIP. ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU AGAIN
RICHARD REID WITH MISSION
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD IN SAN
FRANCISCO SO WE ARE THE
QUARTERBACK FOR A TEAM OF
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING A WEB OF
SUPPORT FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND WE DO SO BY BRINGING
TOGETHER AND COORDINATING EARLY
LEARNING CENTERS COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINICS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE CITY. AND
TOGETHER. WE WORK ALONG THE
CRADLE TO CAREER CONTINUUM TO
CONNECT STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES JOB
TRAINING SMALL BUSINESS LOANS
TAX ASSISTANCE AND MORE. FOR
EXAMPLE WE HELP FAMILY SECURE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
REFUNDS IN THE LAST YEAR ALONE.
AND OVER THE YEARS WE'VE HELP
FAMILIES COMPLETE TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
APPLICATIONS. WITH THIS WEB OF
SUPPORT WE SAW THE CAN TO
READING THIS RATE INCREASE FROM
41% 271% AND THE GRADUATION RATE
INCREASED FROM 68% 286% BUT WHEN
COLBERT FIRST ARRIVED IT HIT OUR
COMMUNITY THE HARDEST. ALTHOUGH
LATINOS ONLY MADE UP 15% OF THE
CITY'S POPULATION. THEY WERE 55%
OF THE KOBE POSITIVE CASES.
BECAUSE OF THEIR CROWDED LIVING
CONDITIONS REFLECTING THE
SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
AND BECAUSE OF THEIR CENTRAL
JOBS THAT COULD BE DONE FROM
HOME. THE TRUST THAT OUR PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOOD HAD BUILT WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND THE NETWORKED
APPROACH WE HAVE DEVELOPED WITH
OTHER AGENCIES PUT US IN A
POSITION TO REACH THESE
FAMILIES. AND TO WORK WITH THE
CITY TO DISTRIBUTE EMERGENCY
RESOURCES INCLUDING EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUNDS TO SIX
THOUSAND FAMILIES. ALLOWING THEM
TO QUARANTINE AT HOME WHEN
NEEDED. AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN RELIEF FUNDS FOR NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. WE USED OUR OLD FEDERAL
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD GRANT TO
COME TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY A
VILLAGE. TO PROVIDE FOR OUR
NEIGHBORS WHO WERE IN GREATEST
NEED. THIS IS GOOD GOVERNMENT.
IT'S COMMUNITY DRIVEN
COLLABORATIVE DATA INFORMED AND
ACCOUNTABLE TO RESULTS. THE IT
TAKES A VILLAGE ACT WILL
INSTITUTIONALIZE THIS APPROACH
SO THAT IT'S NOT LIMITED TO A
FEW LUCKY COMMUNITIES. BUT SCALE
TO REACH MORE OF OUR HARDEST. I
MEAN THAT'S THAT. THIS NEW WAVE
OF PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS COULD
BE THE VANGUARD FOR TRULY
EQUITABLE RECOVERY IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO
EFFORT WE SHOULD HAVE A MISS
GLEASON. THE WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS WHAT THE
POLICE SEND ON BEHALF OF FRESNO
CRADLE TO CAREER IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN.
FRESNO CRADLE TO CAREER OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS FRESNO CQC.
OPERATES THROUGHOUT FRESNO
COUNTY AND INCLUDES THE
LEADERSHIP FROM TEN DIFFERENT
FACTORS. THE MIDDLE MANAGERS
WHICH ARE PROGRAM MANAGERS AND
DIRECTORS. AND GRASSROOTS
LEADERS IN OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND RESIDENTS
FROM MULTIPLE COMMUNITIES ALL
WORKING TOGETHER WITH SHARED
PURPOSE ON MULTIPLE FRONTS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
COLLABORATIVE IN FRESNO COUNTY
IN PLACE THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE WE WERE ABLE- TO MOBILIZE
QUICKLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC. IN THE AREAS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FOOD DISTRIBUTION AND
CHILD CARE FOR ESSENTIAL WORKERS
. AS WE MOVE BEYOND THE PANDEMIC
AND WORKS TO BUILD A NEW NORMAL.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON
BUILDING OUT OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER EFFORTS. AND%
CONTINUING TO PRIORITIZE ACCESS
TO QUALITY CHILDCARE. DIGITAL
INCLUSION IN THE INTERNET ACCESS
ARE ALSO A HIGH PRIORITY AND WE
HAVE ONE OF ONLY TWO COALITIONS
IN CALIFORNIA. ON MIDDLE AND
LAST MILE SOLUTIONS FRESNO
FEATURES FEE CAN BE IN THE
FRESNO COALITION FOR DIGITAL
INCLUSION AND THIS IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE'VE PULLED
TOGETHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
INSTITUTIONS PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AROUND A SHARED VISION AND
COMMITMENT TO COLLABORATION.
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
CRADLE TO CAREER PROSPECTOR
PARTNERSHIP WHICH SHARED VISION
AND COMMITMENT TO COLLABORATION
WE ARE MUCH MORE CONFIDENT THAT
WE CAN TAKE ON BIG CHALLENGES
AND COME UP WITH MEANINGFUL
CHANGE. THIS CROSS SECTOR
COLLABORATIVE BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO MEASURABLY
IMPROVE OUTCOMES IS COMMITTED TO
CENTERING EQUITY. REGULARLY
USING INTEGRATED DATA. ENGAGING
THE COMMUNITY AND BETTER
ALIGNING EXISTING AND NEW PUBLIC
AND PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS IT'S
MANAGED BY A BACKBONE A TEAM
THAT REGULARLY CONVENES MANAGERS
WORK PROGRESS AND REPORTS ON
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT HAS BEEN
VOLUNTARILY FUNDED BY THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. BUT FOR THIS TEAM AND
THEIR ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY
HOLD THE COLLABORATION
ACCOUNTABLE LEADERS WOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK IN SILOS
SKINNER. A PLUS THANK YOU GREAT
. WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY AND
SYMBIOSIS NETWORK ESTABLISHES
AND MAINTAINS THE TRUSTED
RELATIONSHIPS TO BE EFFECTIVE.
IF FIFTEEN IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR THE STATE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE COST OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
. THANK YOU AND WE RESPECTFULLY
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITIES AYE
THOSE. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION THANK
YOU LIVE WILLIAMS WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHILEANS BINDLE WITH MISSION
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE
CALIFORNIA PALMS NEIGHBORHOOD
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT. AMY
CAMPBELL BLARED FROM KLAMATH
RIVER PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD UP ON
THE FAR NORTH COAST STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND HE
SAID YEAH HE MENACE WITH GRACE
AND CHILD POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
PROUD SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
REALLY HONORED TO HAVE THE
MEMBER BONTA LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IT TAKES A VILLAGE ACT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. OPERATIVE WE COULD
GO TO THE PHONES FOR SUPPORT.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY.
MEDICARE NUMBERS MONICA MILLER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED. HELLO
JONATHAN GO NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER GOING STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE ELEVEN.
TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHT CAN STRONG SUPPORT. WINDS
SIXTY SIX. FIFTEEN EIGHT FISHER
WITH THE BRIGHT FUTURES
EDUCATION PARTNERSHIP CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTEEN. ONE ONE OH SIX.
THIS IS BROKE FROST WITH THE
CHILDREN AT FRESNO COUNTY AND
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY. LINE NINETY. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SECOND SHOT OF LIQUOR STRATEGY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD ACTION FUND IN
SUPPORT. ONE ONE THIRTY NINE.
I'M IN THE RIGHT SPCS CALLING IN
SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY FOUR. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS NOT
GOING COOPER FROM THE OPEN MARC
MARON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO AND BEFORE THANK YOU KNOW
. WHY. NINETY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEALTHCARE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
A FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BOETTICHER THERE'S NO ONE
OUT TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OBJECTION HERE
DOES ANYONE POSING ANYONE IN THE
ROOM. OPERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN
LINES FOR ANYONE OPPOSING THIS
BILL. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MADAM CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE. VERY GOOD ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. A
SECOND HERE. ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE BONTA THANK YOU I
SAW THE POST CARD THAT WE
ACTUALLY ED. PUT TOGETHER WHEN
WE LAUNCHED AT THE IT TAKES A
VILLAGE ACT AND BECAUSE A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO AND- I ALONG WITH OUR
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES AND THE VILLAGE OF
LEGISLATORS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A FOR THE FIRST
A SECOND RIGHT. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DAVIES
HI DAVIES I ARAMBULA. BONTA HI
BONTA I'D BRIAN. STONE STONE I'D
BE ABUJA THE ABUJA I WALDRON.
THAT'S FOUR ZERO NOT CHANGING IT
IS. WE BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
UPS MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON. COME ON
DOWN. THIS IS AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
FOUR WHICH ALLOWS CHILDREN AND
YOUNG ADULTS IN FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM A CHANCE TO A TWO STATE
TO A SAFELY- STAY CONNECTED WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES PACIFIC LEAGUE-
ASSEMBLY BILLS- SEVENTEEN NINETY
FOUR WOULD DO THE FOLLOWING.
ENSURE POST ADOPTION CONTRACTS
TO CONTINUE VISITATION BETWEEN
SIBLINGS AND ADDRESS PRIOR TO
TERMINATION OF PARENTAL RIGHTS
ENSURE SIBLINGS VISITATIONS
CONTINUES PAST. THE END OF
PARENTAL RIGHTS CLARIFY THAT
ADULT SIBLINGS- EVEN IF
PREVIOUSLY ADOPTED WORK. VIEW AT
SIBLINGS UNDER THE LAW REQUIRE
THAT OLDER SIBLINGS IN FOSTER
CARE BE GIVEN NOTICE. OF ANY
PLANS TO ADD OF ADOPTION OF
THEIR YOUNGER SIBLINGS AND ALLOW
PARENTAL RIGHTS TO BE A
REINSTATED FOR NON MINERS IN
FOSTER CARE AFTER AN ADOPTION
HAS FAILED. THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC THROUGH COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS CHILDREN- YOUNG ADULTS
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT I'M
CONTINUING TO BE CORRECT TO BE-
CONNECTED WITH THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES IS
EXPRESSLY CRITICAL- TO SIBLINGS
BEING A BROTHER A FATHER IT IS
HARD TO IMAGINE. BEING WITHOUT-
THE BOND WITH MY SIBLINGS-
DURING WHAT WE CAN. WHEN WE CAN
IS THE START OF A BETTER FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
TIMES A DAY IMAGINE ONE HUNDRED
TIMES A DAY A CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA IS PLACED IN FOSTER
CARE. LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE
HAS OVER THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH AND IT TAKES AND IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THESE CHILDREN
WHO WANT TO LIVE WITH THEIR
BIRTH PARENTS TO HAVE AN OPTION
TO KEEPING THEIR FAMILY
CONNECTED. IN SOME CASES THE
ADOPTION FAIL FAILS AND THE
CHILDREN HAS BEEN RE
ESTABLISHED- A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEIR PARENTS HOWEVER. THE
STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT OF THIS
PROCESS IT ABSOLUTELY LACKS
OLDER FOSTER YOUTH NEEDS HELP
WHEN FOSTER YOU TURNED OUT OF
THE SYSTEM THEY ARE LEFT WITHOUT
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED.
HAVING FAMILY CONNECTION DURING
THIS TIMES PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
THAT IS NEEDED FOR THAT FAMILY
BOND AS A MEMBER OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS. I AM ALSO AWARE OF THE
CRISIS WITH THE NATIVE AMERICAN
FOSTER YOUTH THE CRISIS IS
SIMILAR IN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THAT THE-
COMMUNITY FAMILY CULTURES
CONNECTION MATTERS AND IT IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT ASSEMBLY
BUILD SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR
STRENGTHENS FAMILY CONNECTION.
EVERY CHILD DESERVES A LOVING
AND A PERMANENT RELATIONSHIP
EVERY CHILD DESERVES. TO FEEL
SAFE WANTED LOVE AND HURT BY THE
COMMUNITY THEY IDENTIFY WITH AND
FOSTER COMMUNITY FOSTER
COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS WITH THAT
COMMUNITY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
NINETY FOUR PROVIDES A PATH
FORWARD FOR THESE FAMILIES
JOINING ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY BY PHONE- IS MERITED
ALEXANDER SUPERVISING ATTORNEY
WITH THE CHILDREN LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK SHE IS
SHOULD BE ON THE PHONE IF YOU
SHOULD BE ON THE PHONE THAT'S
CORRECT OPERATOR YES I'M HERE
CAN. YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FIRST I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON FOR
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL
STRENGTHEN FAMILY CONNECTIONS
AND ULTIMATELY FOSTER BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH INVOLVED IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
UNMERITED ALEXANDER AN ATTORNEY
SUPERVISOR AT THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA. I WAS
PREVIOUSLY A CASE CARRYING
ATTORNEY FOR CLC REPRESENTING
CHILDREN AND DEPENDENCY COURT
DALY AND BEFORE JOINING CLC I
WORKED IN FAMILY LAW. CLC IS THE
LARGEST CHILDREN'S LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATION IN THE
NATION ADVOCATING FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE IN LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER
COUNTY EACH YEAR. IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM IF A CHILD CANNOT
SAFELY BE REUNIFIED WITH THEIR
FAMILY ADOPTION IS THE PREFERRED
PLAN. PERMANENT IS CRITICAL FOR
OUR CLIENTS BUT THERE IS ALSO A
GROWING RECOGNITION THAT FOR
MANY ADOPTEES IT IS ALSO
CRITICAL TO MAINTAIN SOME
CONNECTION TO THEIR BIOLOGICAL
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY. AND THAT
MAINTAINING THESE CONNECTIONS
CAN OFTEN BE SAFE AND PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS. I'VE SEEN
IN NUMEROUS CASES THAT WHILE
ADOPTION CAN BRING GREAT JOY
THERE CAN ALSO BE A SIGNIFICANT
GRIEF AND LOSS WHEN A CHILD IS
PERMANENTLY CUT FROM ALL
CONNECTION TO THEIR FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY. RESEARCH SHOWS THE
SIBLING BOND IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN MITIGATING THE
TRAUMA OF FAMILY SEPARATION. THE
BACK WE HEAR FROM OUR CLIENT HAS
REINFORCED THE VERACITY OF THIS
RESEARCH. WELL THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAINTAINING SIBLING CONNECTIONS
POSTED OPTION IS ALREADY
RECOGNIZED IN THE LAW BY
REQUIRING CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES
TO SET UP A MEETING TO EXECUTE
OPPOSED ADOPTION CONTRACT FOUR
SIBLINGS WHEN PRACTICABLE. IN
PRACTICE WE RARELY SEE THESE
MEETINGS TAKE PLACE AND TOO
OFTEN WE SEE OUR CLIENTS LOSE
ALL CONTACT WITH THEIR SIBLINGS
RESULTING IN TRAUMA THAT CAN
LAST WELL INTO ADULTHOOD. THIS
BILL AN EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE
THESE MEETINGS DO TAKE PLACE TO
DISCUSS THE POSSIBILITY OF POSTS
ADOPTION CONTACT BETWEEN
SIBLINGS. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE PATHWAYS TO
REINSTATE PARENTAL RIGHTS FOR
USE WHEN IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
AND IN THEIR BEST INTEREST. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND AGAIN
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GETS SENT
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR. WE SHOULD HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS ON THE PHONE- MISS
EVELYN FISCAL. I DON'T THINK SO
THIS IS ONLY ONE. ALL RIGHT DO
WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT ON THE BILL
IN THE ROOM. OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD GO TO THE LINES FOR
SUPPORT PLEASE. ALL FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. LINE. ONE HUNDRED. HI THIS IS JOHN
HIGH GO WITH THE CALVET. HI THIS
IS JOHN AND THEN GO WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR THANK YOU
. ONE ONE ELEVEN. CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BILLION RIGHT TO FROM
SUPPORT. WINDS. SEVENTY THREE.
JOINT MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL CALIFORNIA- PRAGUE
FUNDS ARE OF THE FELL APART
THANK YOU. WILL NOW GO TO LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. KEWLEY LOS LOS
ANGELES POTENTIAL LAWYERS AND
THE COURT. FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. BUT I'M SURE THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. SEEING NONE GONNA MOVE TO ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD GO TO THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION PLACE. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE AND
SERVE YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. BOB PARDON ME IN
OPPOSITION. FIRST NO ONE. THANK
YOU OPERATOR MEMBERS ANY INCOMES
THANK YOU WILL GET A FIRST AND
SECOND WULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN WE
WANT TO THANK- MEREDITH-
ALEXANDER- WITH THE CHILDREN
LAWCENTERFOR GIVING HER
TESTIMONY ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR
STRENGTHENS A PROCESS THAT WOULD
UP LIVE FAMILY CONNECTIONS UP
FOR ADOPTION WHEN APPROPRIATE
THIS BILL SUPPORT- SUPPORT.
CONNECTING CONNECT A CONTACT
BETWEEN SIBLINGS IN A VERY SAFE
AND THOUGHTFUL WAY IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO CREATE UNIFICATION I'M
FOR FAMILIES- WHEN NECESSARY
WHEN IT'S IMPORTANT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND- WHEN THEIR FAMILY IS
SEPARATED- IT'S HARD FOR THEM TO
RE EXTEND SCOTT ACT AND IF I
CLOSE EVEN WILL DOUBLE TWO YEARS
AGO I AUTHORED A BILL THAT DEALS
IN THE SAME FASHION- A YOUNG MAN
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS BODY HUMAN
SERVICES. AND KEY WORDS TWIN
BROTHER AND THEY WERE FIVE
SIBLINGS AND THEY WERE
SEPARATED- AND NOT KNOW THAT HIS
TWIN BROTHER LIVED FIVE BLOCKS
AWAY THE SOCIAL WORKER DECIDED
TO GO AGAINST THE RULES AND RE.
BOTH BROTHERS WHO ATTENDED THE
SAME SCHOOL DIDN'T EVEN THOUGH
THEY ATTENDED THE SAME SCHOOL
AND TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE
REUNIFICATION TOOK PLACE THE
RISK. AND INDEED THE ABILITY FOR
HIM TO CONNECT WITH HIS
BIOLOGICAL TWIN BROTHER. YEAH IT
ALSO. STOPPED ABILITY TO SEE
WHETHER NOT THERE'S MANNERISMS
THAT HE- SHARED WITH HIS TWIN
BROTHER- OR ANY SIMILARITIES OF
MOTHER AND FATHER AND SO THIS
BILL IS A THOUGHTFUL WAY TO
MAKING SURE. IN CASES TO THAT
THERE IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO RE
UNIFY- THAT FAMILY STRUCTURE
SPECIALLY AMONG SIBLINGS WE DO
JUST THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHAT I VOTE FOR. IT THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DAVIES AYE DAVIES AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BONTA.
BRIAN BRIAN ICE STONE I'D BE
APPROVED BY THE VALLAPUDUA I
WALDRON. RIGHT THAT BILL IS FIVE
TWO ZERO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JUST TO GET SOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF. I WE'LL
START WITH THAT- AB TWENTY
NINETY THAT WORKS GREAT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THERE ARE LONGSTANDING CONCERNS
REGARDING THE HIGHER WORKLOADS
THAT SOCIAL WORKERS IN CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES FACE. WHEN
WORKLOADS BECOME UNMANAGEABLE IT
NOT ONLY AFFECTS THE SOCIAL
WORKER BUT IT ALSO AFFECTS THE
WELL BEING OF THE CHILDREN THE
YOUTH AND THE FAMILIES WHO ARE
BEING SERVED. SOME COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS THESE
FACTORS. AS COUNTIES ARE ABLE TO
REACH THEIR RATIO GOALS THEY
SHOULD BE PROPERLY RECOGNIZED
FOR THEIR EFFORTS AND BEST
PRACTICES. AB TWENTY NINETY WILL
PROVIDE FISCAL INCENTIVES TO
COUNTIES WHO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
GUIDELINES FOR CHILD WELFARE
SOCIAL WORKER WORKLOAD RATIOS.
THUS REWARDING THE GOOD ACTORS
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL WHO LABOR TO
CARE FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH.
REBECA GONZALEZ FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IS ON
THE PHONE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINETY THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ AND I REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
REPRESENT SOCIAL WORKERS WITH A
DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK FROM AN
ACCREDITED SCHOOL ACOSTA BURKE
I'M HERE BONSER TWENTY NINETY
WHICH WILL PROVIDE FISCAL
INCENTIVES TO COUNTY MAKE
CALIFORNIA GUIDELINES FOR CHILD
WELFARE SOCIAL WORKER. WORKLOAD
RATIOS IN THIRTEEN STATES PUBLIC
CHILD WELFARE ADMINISTRATORS
HIGH WORKLOAD ENERGY FUNDS WERE
AMONG THE TOP REASONS BUT
PREVENTABLE TURNOUT BURKE STAFF
TURNOVER IS ALSO COSTLY TO
AGENCIES WHEN CONSIDERING
SEPARATION. RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING COSTS. NOT TO MENTION
THE HARM CHILDREN THEY'RE QUE
ARE GIVEN THE IT'S THEY DID.
HOLD TIME DUE TO HIGH CASELOAD
HAS SEVERAL AFFECT CONFLICT WITH
THE PRINCIPLE OF STRENGTH BASED
INDIVIDUALIZED CARE. INCLUDING
THE DIFFICULTY FACED BY CASE
WORKERS TO DO THEIR JOBS AND
THEY ARE OFTEN CORRECT REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE LONG TERM
COMPREHENSIVE AND INTENSIVE
SERVICES IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
COMPLEX. AND MULTI FACETED NEEDS
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
INVOLVED IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. HAVE NOTED THE VERY
IMPACT THE WORKLOAD WITHIN
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICE SETTINGS
INCLUDING CHILD WELFARE
EXCESSIVE WORKLOADS TEND TO
INCREASE WORKER STRESS AND
REDUCE THEIR BIOLOGICAL AND
PHYSICAL WELL BEING WHICH IN
TURN LEAD TO A HIGHER LEVEL OF
TURNOVER. IN ADDITION WORKLOAD
CONTRIBUTES TO CASE WORKERS AT
CAPACITY TO ENGAGE CHILDREN AND
FAMILY PROVIDE QUALITY SERVICES
AND ACCOMPLISH INTENDED OUTCOME.
EFFECTIVE WORKLOAD MANAGEMENT IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM CAN
ALLOW CASE WORKERS TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ON INVESTIGATION CASE
PLANNING AND EVALUATION
THEREFOREVERIFY EFFECTIVELY
ACHIEVING SAFETY PERMANENCY AND
WELL BEING FOR THE CHILDREN THEY
SERVE. WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
HELP INCENTIVIZE COUNTY IMPROVE
OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM ANY.
CALIFORNIA PERFECT WAY OUT HERE
I VOTE ON AB TWENTY NINETY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ DO. WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE AMENDED- FOR
THE REASONS THAT- IF WE NEED TO
ADVANCE THE NUMBER OF SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
MEET THE RATIO REQUIREMENTS IT
WOULD BE A COST. THAT WE DON'T
ON HAVE THE FUNDING CURRENTLY TO
PROVIDE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT WE
DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO MEET
THOSE GOALS. SO TO PROVIDE THE
FUNDING AND ALSO LOOKING AT THE
RATIOS FROM THE DATE IT WAS
ESTABLISHED WE THINK THAT THERE
IS. A MODIFICATION THE MAKING
SURE THAT WE MEET THOSE GOALS
APPROPRIATELY TO DATE WITH THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD AND
INTENSIVE CARE THAT WE'VE
LEARNED ALONG THE WAY AND WHAT
IS NEEDED FOR THE CHILDREN. TO
PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT SO WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF WE CAN HAVE- A
CLOSER LOOK AT. RATIOS ACTUALLY
NEEDED IN TODAY'S- ENVIRONMENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
OPERATIVE WE COULD GO TO THE
PHONES FOR SUPPORT PLEASE. HEY
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. PRESS ONE ZERO. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANYWAY MCAFEE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA MY SINCERE
APOLOGIES FOR NOT GETTING A
LETTER IN KIND I'M COMING IN TO
PUT OF AB TWENTY NINETY THANK
YOU. ONE ONE ELEVEN.
CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY RIGHTS
WISCONSIN FOR. WINE. ONE
HUNDRED. HEY ONE ONE HUNDRED
YEAR ONE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO JOHN
DIDN'T GO NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SERVERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT. I'M SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. SAYING
NONE OF ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. OPERATIVE YOU CAN GO TO
THE LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION
PLEASE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE
WHO SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU MISTER FURTHER MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS- IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU DO I HAVE A MOTION.
SOME OF THE SECOND GREAT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DAVIES AYE DAVIES AYE
ARAMBULA HI ARAMBULA I'D BONTA
HI BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN IS STONE
STONE I BE APPROVED BY. THE
VALLAPUDUA I WALDRON. ALL RIGHT
THEN TO BILL IS FIVE TWO ZERO
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS BECAUSE WE HAVE
ANOTHER ONE SIX. WE'RE BUILDING
SLOWLY BUT SURELY. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE LOW LET YOU GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO AB TWO FIVE
NINE ZERO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS
ARE BENEFICIAL FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS AS THEY TRANSITION
THROUGHOUT THEIR CAREER. AB
TWENTY FIVE NINE ESTABLISHES A
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
PILOT PROGRAM TO DEVELOP A
MENTORSHIP PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS. BY PROVIDING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WE WILL SEE THE
BENEFITS IN SOCIAL WORKER JOB
RETENTION WHICH WILL ULTIMATELY
BENEFIT THE FAMILY WHO DEPEND ON
SOCIAL WORKERS. AGAIN I HAVE
REBEKAH GONZALEZ FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WHO'S
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY FIVE NINETY. I'M HELLO
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH ANY F. W.
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE AT THE
SPONSORED AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH A
MENTORSHIP PILOT PROGRAM FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS TO HELP THEM WITH
THEIR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND BECAUSE THEIR LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT AND SOCIAL WORK.
RESEARCHERS SHOWN THE YOUNGER
SOCIAL WORKERS REPORT LOW
PERSONAL ACCOMPLISHMENT HIGHER
PSYCHOLOGIC COAL AND MORE DEEP
PERSONALIZATION THAN OLDER
SOCIAL WORKERS. IT TAKES ABOUT
TWO YEARS FOR NEW SOCIAL WORKER
TO FULLY LEARN THEIR JOB
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
TURNOVER RATES ARE HIGH
ESPECIALLY IN CHILD WELFARE
SETTINGS AND IT IS EXPENSIVE AND
TIME CONSUMING TO FIND
REPLACEMENTS NEW HIRES WHO HAD
ACCESS TO A MENTOR TEND TO BE
MARKED. WHERE DOES NOT. EVEN
AFTER THEIR SOCIAL WORK MEDICAL
ARE NOT FOR THEM ALSO SOURCE
WORK RESEARCHER DISCOVER THAT IN
GRADUATING A SOCIAL HAVE MOM ON
HOW DO I GET BERNIE AND
COMPASSION FATIGUE OR HOW TO
PRACTISE SELF CARE STRONG
MENTORSHIP FOR NEW HIRES AND
EXPERIENCES THAT STRENGTHEN THE
FIRST. WHAT I DON'T CRITICAL
THIRD PEOPLE OF THE STATE.
SUPPORTING THESE INDIVIDUALS.
AND HELPING OUR COMMUNITY. AND
MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS ARE
BENEFICIAL WAY FOR SOCIAL WORKER
CHECK TRANSITION THROUGHOUT
THEIR CAREER RESEARCH WAS BILLS
THAT HELP IN A MEASURE TO TALK
DURING ONE. STRAPPED AND HELPS
IT. ONE GAVE A CLEAR NUMBER TO
MAKE INFORMED. IN THE BROWN OF
THE FOLKS WHO WORK FOR CAN CHAO
TO DIDN'T ARE MERGING PROFESSION
STRUGGLING TO FIND IN THIS.
MATTER SUPPORT THAT THEY BY THE
PROFESSOR STRENGTH AND IDENTIFY
THEIR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
NEEDS. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO INCREASE EFFORT TO
FOSTER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY FOR IMPACT A
CAREER SUCH AS SOCIAL WORKERS BY
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS WE WILL
BENEFIT SOCIAL WORKER JOB
RETENTION WHICH WILL ULTIMATELY
BENEFIT THE FAMILY DEPEND ON
SOCIAL WORK BUT EXCLUDE EACH
REASONS WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THAT. THANK YOU THANK. YOU DO WE
HAVE ANY SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
OPERATIVE YOU GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR SUPPORT PLEASE. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. HEY. ONE ONE
EIGHT. ANYWAY WHAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. ONE ONE ELEVEN. TWENTY SIX
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY RIGHT FROM
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU OPERATOR WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO OPPOSITION DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSED
THIS THING NINE ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM. OPERATE IF YOU GO
TO PHONE LINES FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE. SHIFTS TO THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SH MADAM
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE. THANK YOU
OPERATOR OF MEMBERS IN THE
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT OF IF YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU DR A
MOTION OF THE DEBTOR. GETS IT
RIGHT AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS THE PAST
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DAVIS AYE DAVIES AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BONTA AYE
BONTA HI BRIAN. BRIAN IS STONE.
STONE I THE ABUJA- THE ABUJA I
WALDRON. THE VOTE IS SIX TWO
ZERO AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. OF
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WANT TO
GO BACK AND WILL COVER THE BILLS
THAT WOULD IN HITCHIN THANK YOU
. ST FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWO FIVE
ONE SEVEN THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR TWO ZERO ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
I'M BRIAN. BRIAN I AND WALDRON.
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO. FILE
ITEM NINE AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX
WE TOOK TESTIMONY WE NEED A
MOTION. AND A SECOND. THE MOTION
IS THE PAST TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DAVIES
DAVIES NOW ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
BONTA BONTA ONLINE BRIAN. RYAN I
STONE STONE IV ABBOUD WANNA BE A
GOOD ONE I WALDRON. CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE TO ONE. FILE ITEM TEN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE WE TOOK
TESTIMONY I NEED A MOTION SECOND
. I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DAVIES DAVIES I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA IRA BONTA.
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I STONE
STONE IV VALLAPUDUA. THE
VALLAPUDUA I WALDRON. CURRENT
CREDIT SIXTIES ERA. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWO ONE FIVE NINE WE
TOOK TESTIMONY I NEED A MOTION
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DAVIES DAVIES I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BONTA.
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN AYE STONE.
STONE IV VALLAPUDUA. UDVAR I
WALDRON KERN VERY SIXTIES ERA.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWO THREE
ZERO NINE WE TOOK TESTIMONY I
NEED A MOTION. MOTION BY DAVIS
SECOND BY STONE. I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU MOTION BY SOME
SECOND BY DAVIS. THE MOTION IS
THE PAST TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DAVIES
DAVIES I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
BONTA. BONTA I BRIAN BRIAN AYE
STONE STONE IV ABBOUD WHAT. GOOD
LUCK I WALDRON THE CURRENT VOTER
SIX TO ZERO. FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
AB ONE SEVEN NINE FOUR CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO BONTA.
BONTA I WALDRON CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX TWO ZERO. ON FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN ARAMBULA VOTED I. FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO THREE ZERO
ZERO CURRENT VOTERS FOR TWO ZERO
ARAMBULA REGULAR I BRIAN. RYAN I
WALDRON CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO. FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
TWO SIX SIX THREE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE TWO ZERO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BRIAN. BRAND I
WALDRON CURRENT VOTE THIS FIVE
TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
AB TWO EIGHT THREE TWO CURRENT
VOTERS FOUR TO ZERO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BRIAN. BRAND I AND
WALDRON CURRENT VOTED SIX TO
ZERO. HEY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CURRENT VOTERS FIVE
TWO ZERO ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HIGH
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO. WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR ON SEPTEMBER
JONES SAWYER AS WELL AS A SALAS
. THEY SHOULD BE HERE ANY TIME.
YEAH. AT LEAST THE NEXT. YEAH.
YEAH. GET. SOMETIMES THE ON THE. WELCOME TO SALAS. WE ARE IN A. NINETEEN FOR ONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THINK YOU MEMBERS
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN FORTY ONE I DO
WANT TO STATE THAT IT WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- THIS BILL GIVES LOW
TO NO INCOME SENIORS AND
DISABLED AND INDIVIDUALS AN
ADDITIONAL SIX DOLLARS AND
SOCIAL SECURITY PAYMENTS TO
SENIORS AND BLIND AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS. ANY YEAR THERE IS A
BUDGET SURPLUS SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTED YOU HAVE
TESTIMONY- WITH ME TODAY. THANK
YOU GO HEAD- MADAM CHAIR MIKE
CARROLL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY- WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL-
WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA'S
PARTICULARLY- SSI RECIPIENTS-
AND JUST AS A REMINDER THERE ONE
POINT. ONE MILLION PEOPLE WHO
DEPEND ON THAT SIDE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR LIVING
THERE COSTS. THERE BRENT THEIR
UTILITIES EVERY MONTH- FOR OVER
A DECADE WE IMPOSED A CUT TO
THOSE FAMILIES. OF SOME SEVENTY
SEVEN DOLLARS A MONTH ALL
THROUGH THE RECESSION EVEN TO
THE POINT WHERE WE HAD A BIG
SURPLUS WE CONTINUE TO- CUT
THOSE BENEFITS. LAST YEAR WE
WERE ABLE TO GET THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR PAYMENT- THAT WENT OUT TO
ALL RECIPIENTS. UNDER THE GOLDEN
STATE GRANT THANKS TO THE GOOD
WORK OF GOVERNOR. NEWSOM AND THE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP WE WERE
ABLE TO GET THAT ESTABLISHED.
AND I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE AND SS I
RECIPIENTS. WHO CAN TESTIFY TO
THE BENEFITS OF THAT. FROM LAST
YEAR. VERY GOOD. WE HAVE A MISS
JACKSON. YES IT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS JUDY JACKSON I
RECEIVED A TEST BY I HAVE
SEVERAL MEDICAL PROBLEMS AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THE GRANT DID
FOR ME. WAS I HAVE TROUBLE
KEEPING THE FRUITS THAT I GET
FROM THE FOOD BANK. AND I WITH
THE GRANT I WAS ABLE TO PURCHASE
A SMALL FREEZER A LITTLE BIT
LARGER THAN A WASHING MACHINE.
AND NOW I GET THE FOOD DOES NOT
SPOIL I CAN. PUT IT IN THE
FREEZER AND KEEP IT AND THAT WAY
I CAN HAVE A SMOOTHIE EVERYDAY
PURCHASE WHAT I NEED TO ARE
REALLY APPRECIATED THE CRAP.
THANK YOU VERY MUH. DO WE HAVE
ANY SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DUANE CAMP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE PLEASE. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. HE HE HE- JOSH. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
ELEVEN. TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY RIGHT TO STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY NINE. HI
ROBERT COLORBLOCK TOWARD ARE
DARK BUT WITH THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS GROUP IN SACRAMENTO-
STRONG SUPPORT. FINE. ONE THIRTY
FIVE. TRANSPONDERS FOR FIFTEEN
AGING AIRPORT. ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE A ADDITIONAL PERSON TO
SIGNAL BUT WISH TO SPEAK.
I'M GONNA GO TO LINE OF ONE
THIRTY FIVE PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT I PARDON ME. HELLO THIS
IS JONATHAN GOES NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. NINETEEN
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. AND FINAL
CALL OF ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE RESPOND
WITH THE ONE AND ZERO. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
. OPERATIVE WE CAN GO TO PHONE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THERE IS NO ONE. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE BILL THAT. RESULTS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AB NINETEEN
FORTY ONE WILL HELP SENIORS AND
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS ON FIXED
INCOMES SO THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO
JUST CHOOSE BETWEEN PUTTING FOOD
ON THE TABLE OR- EYEING THEIR
MEDICATIONS RESPECTFULLY AK
RIVAL. THINK IF I CAN OF A SHIP
JUMPED IN THERE JUST ONE
QUESTION MIGHT. THIS IS A GREAT
BILL MIKE MY CONCERN IS THERE'S
REALLY NOTHING TO FIND ANSWER
PLUS SO WHAT IF THE IN THE YEAR
WE HAVE A SURPLUS OF SAY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE STATE.
HOW'S THAT GOING TO GO OUT
COMPARED TO IS THERE CAP OR
CERTAIN NUMBER THERE HAS TO BE
WHEN YOU KNOW SO THAT YOU GET
ONE POINT MILLION. OF THAT ARE
TOM I THINK WE'VE ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WILL FURTHER-
DEFINE THOSE WILL IN
APPROPRIATIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DAVIES.
NAPOLI DAVIS NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
. BONTA HI BONTA I BRIAN RYAN
AYE STONE STONE IDEA PUT TO. BE
ABLE TO DO WHAT I WALDRON.
SKYWORKS. THAT BILLS GOES FOUR
ZERO AND WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
OF WORLD FOR ANY OF THE MEMBERS
. IT WILL BE JUST WAITING FOR US
TO REMEMBER JOIN SORRY FOR THE
LAST BILL MUCH.
GOOD YEAH. WELL DONE THANK YOU
NOT HAVE OUR COMPLETE ATTENTION
. GOOD MORNING CARE MEMBERS I AM
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB- TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FIVE A BILL THAT
WOULD ENSURE THAT CANNABIS IS
TREATED JUST AS ANY OTHER LEGAL
SUBSTANCE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CHILD CUSTODY AND DEPENDENCY
COURT OFFICE MADE HAD BEEN AWARE
OF INCIDENTS WERE FAMILIES ARE
BROUGHT INTO DEPENDENCY COURT
FOR THE MERE POSSESSION OF
ILLEGAL CANNABIS WITHOUT ANY
EVIDENCE OF CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS MERE
POSSESSION OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS
IS INSUFFICIENT TO TAKE CUSTODY
OF A FAMILY UNDER CASE LAW. YET
AND STILL WE ARE AWARE OF
SITUATION WHERE FAMILIES ARE
DRAGGED INTO COURT MERELY DUE TO
POSSESSION OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS
TO BE CLEAR. THIS BILL DOES NOT
MAKE ANY CHANGES TO THE CHILD
WELFARE INVESTIGATION PROCESS OR
ANY PROCEEDINGS IT ONLY REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT AT OVERSEAS
INVESTIGATIONS. TO ENSURE THAT
ALL REGULATIONS GUIDANCE GIVEN
TO COUNTY STREETS CANVAS THE
SAME AS ALCOHOL OR LEGALLY CRIED
MEDICATION. DRIVE FAMILIES INTO
COURT FOR POSSESSION OF CANNABIS
IS NOT ONLY A STRESSFUL EVENT
THERE WERE CARS TAKING TIME OFF.
OR JUGGLING SCHEDULES BE
INCREDIBLY TRAUMATIC FOR. THIS
BILL MAKE SURE THAT
INVESTIGATION STILL HAVE THE
TOOLS INVESTIGATORS ARE TO
DETERMINE NEGLECT OR ABUSE BUT
DOES NOT BURDEN FAMILIES FOR THE
LEGAL POSSESSION OF. OF CANNABIS
WITH ME TO PRESENT BY PHONE IS
BURKE HUGHLEY FROM THE LOS
ANGELES DEPENDENCY LAWYERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. MISTER LAKE ONLINE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BROOKE
HUGHLEY I'M A SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY AT LAW SANDALS AND THE
LAWYERS WERE THE LARGEST FAMILY
DEFENSE ORGANIZATION OF OUR KIND
IN THE NATION AND WE REPRESENT
AROUND TWENTY THOUSAND PARENTS
AND THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM ON
ANY GIVEN DAY. THESE SPONSOR AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FIVE WHICH
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO UPDATE ITS
CONSTRUCTION. WORK HELD NEGLECT
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING
CANNABIS USE. IN MAJOR ISSUE
FACING OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
TODAY INVOLVES THE DISPARATE
TREATMENT APPARENTLY THE
CANNABIS PERSON. ALCOHOL ARE
LEGALLY PRESCRIBED MEDICATION.
IT'S CLOSE THE TIED TO AND
SOCIOECONOMIC BIAS. TWENTY
TWELVE THE COURT OF APPEAL HAS
CONSISTENTLY HELD THAT A PARENT
CANNABIS USE ALONE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT FOR THE STATE TO
ENTER HERE AND THE FAMILY. RIGHT
I THINK THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
HOLD TO THE SYSTEM SIMPLY
BECAUSE APPARENTLY YOU CANNOT AT
SOME POINT IN THE MAJORITY OF
THESE CASES THE CHILD IS DOING
WELL AND THE PHONE HE WANTS TO
BE WITH THEIR PARENTS AND HAS
NEVER BEEN ABUSED OR NEGLECTED
HOWEVER WHEN A PARENT DISCLOSES
CANNABIS USE PAST OR PRESENT
SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE FIELD ARE
SIMPLY PRESUMING CHILD NEGLECT.
EVEN WITHOUT ANY FACTS TO BACK
THAT UP AND WHAT'S WORSE IS
OFTEN USED AS A PRETEXT TO BE
STRAPPED INTO SEPARATE FAMILIES
OF COLOR AS A RESULT OF THESE
WORKERS DECISION A CHILD
SUFFERS. THE AGENCY THE JACKSON
FAMILY THE CONSTANT PHONE CALLS
DROPPIN INTERROGATIONS AND
ACCUSATIONS THE FAMILY
FUNCTIONING AT THIS RAPID AND
THE PARENTS AND CHILDREN LIVE IN
FEAR OF BEING INVOLUNTARILY
SEPARATED AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FIVE WILL HELP TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE SCHERING THAT THE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE GIVEN PROPER
GUIDANCE. THAT WAY PPARENTLY
STAPLE USES CANNABIS IS TREATED
THE SAME AS THE CURRENT
RESPONSIBLY HAS A GLASS OF WINE
OR WHO TAKE LEGALLY PRESCRIBED
MEDICATION FOR THE TREATMENT L.
A. DEPENDENCY LAWYERS EXPRESSED
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
SUPPORTING ROOM. OPERATIVE WE
CAN GO THE PHONE LINES FOR
PLEASE. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE AND YOUR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WELL NOW GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY FOUR. HI THIS IS
JOHN TO GO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS RICHARD MILLER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR AMERICAN
ALLIANCE FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS
AND ALSO I AM A DE FACTO CURRENT
THAT IS BEEN AFFECTED BY THIS I
WOULD REQUEST AND RESPECTFULLY
CRUSHED YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
. LINE ONE NINETEEN. ONE ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MINIMAL BONTA LINE WHAT. PARDON
ME BY ONE NINETEEN CONSTRUCTS
ONE THEN ZERO GUN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO LINE. ONE FORTY
SEVEN. HI THIS IS ELLEN KAHN
FROM CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FIVE. WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO LINE ONE NINETEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TALLY
TOMORROW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WIND ONE ELEVEN. RIGHT NEXT
CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY RIGHTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. ANYONE ELSE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES NOT POSITION.
SEEING NOW AND WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN TAKE THIS TO LINE FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE. YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE.
THANK YOU- COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS. RESPOND TO SPLIT THE
BILL. OKAY MISTER AND SIR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO FINISH UP
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
TAKE ROPE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DAVIES NOT FUNDING
DAVIS NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I'D BONTA HI BONTA HI
BRIAN BRIAN I STONE STONE I BE
APPROVED BY THE VALLAPUDUA I
WALDRON. THE LOTUS. SIX SIX FIVE
ZERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO AT THIS TIME I
WOULD THANK HIM EVERYONE FOR
STAYING HERE. WE'RE LIVE THE
CALLS. MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND- ANY
MEMBERS CAN ADD ON VOTES. FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE AB ONE NINE
FOUR ONE THE CURRENT VOTERS FOUR
TO ZERO. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HIGH
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ZERO.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR KERN
VOTE SIX TO ZERO WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FINAL VOTE SEVEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM ONE AB TWO ZERO
NINE ZERO CURRENT VOTE SIX TO
ZERO WALDRON AND WALDRON RYAN
FINAL VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
THREE AB TWO FIVE NINE ZERO
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO WALDRON
WALDRON I FINAL VOTE FROM IT IS
THERE ARE. FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
TWO FIVE ONE SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
SIX TO ZERO WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
FINAL VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
NINE AB ONE SIX EIGHT SIX
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ONE WALDRON
WALDRON I FINAL VOTE SIX TO ONE
. FILE ITEM EIGHT TEN AB ONE
EIGHT SIX ONE CURRENT VOTE SIX
TO ZERO WALDRON WALDRON AYE
FINAL VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWO ONE FIVE NINE
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO WALDRON
. MOTOR NOT VOTING FINAL VOTE
SIX TO ZERO. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB TWO THREE ZERO NINE CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FINAL VOTE SEVEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB ONE
SEVEN NINE FOUR CURRENT VOTE SIX
TO ZERO WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
FINAL VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB TWO FIVE NINE FIVE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE FINAL VOTE
SIX TO ZERO. FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
AB TWO THREE ZERO ZERO CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO WALDRON WALDRON
AYE FINAL VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB TWO SIX SIX
THREE CURRENT VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO
WALDRON WALDRON I AM FINAL VOTE. SIX TO ZERO. FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO AB TWO EIGHT THREE TWO
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO
WALDRON. WALDRON I AM FINAL VOTE
SEVENTIES ERA. FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE AB ONE NINE FOUR ONE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ZERO
WALDRON WALDRON AYE FINAL VOTE
SIX TO ZERO.
THIS IS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES BUSINESSES
COMPLETE WINTER.